- Hey everybody,
welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is the
phenomenal Alexi Pappas.
I love this woman. She
is truly extraordinary.
She is an Olympics athlete.
She competed in Rio in the
10,000 meters for Greece,
but she's also a poet,
a writer, a film maker.
She co-wrote, co-directed and
starred in two feature films.
And she's also an author.
Her new book is called "Bravey".
It's a beautiful, lovely read.
I highly suggest
everybody check it out.
And this conversation
is amazing.
So hit that subscribe button
and please enjoy
this conversation
with my new favorite person.
(upbeat music)
Well, I'm so thrilled to finally
meet you and talk to you.
And to kind of introduce this,
it's a little embarrassing,
but like I knew who you were
and I had a sense of the
things that you had done
and are involved in, but
I didn't like know you.
And then when the New York
times Op-Doc came out,
I was really moved by that
and Lindsey's a mutual friend
and that kind of prompted me
to do a deeper dive
into your life.
And that happened to coincide
with your publicist reaching
out about doing the show,
which I was like immediately,
yes, please come on the show.
So I've spent like the
last week really enjoying
like all the different
things that you've done.
I watched both movies.
I'm well into your book.
The book is so good.
It's fantastic.
Like you did such
a remarkable job.
I love the movies and you're
like my new favorite person
so I'm all nervous
to talk to you,
and this is just super exciting.
- Well, it's exciting for me
and it's exciting for me
in more ways than one.
I admire how committed
you are to what you do,
and how interesting
and interested you are.
But also my best friend
since two years old,
you are like the greatest thing
to her and you've kept her,
she's actually a COVID nurse
and you have kept her
company on like mountain runs
and long drives to the
hospital in Denver.
And when she learned
that this was happening,
suddenly, she was like this
is the most exciting thing
you have ever done
Alexi, and I've done...
I'm very proud of my life-
- Now you feel so much pressure.
I'm touched.
- No! No!
It meant so much to
me in the same way
that she used to love,
like Rihanna, for example,
and I didn't love
Rihanna music growing up,
but Amanda, my best
friend in the world
loved Rihanna music so much.
And you know when someone
you love is like joyful,
you begin to like the
things that make them happy.
I felt like my excitement
was like compounded
with the joy and
excitement that she had.
And she really is the
coolest person I know.
And since you're the
coolest person she knows,
then that makes
this very exciting.
- Well, what's up Amanda?
Thank you for that.
I appreciate it.
Thank you for listening.
- That's amazing.
- That's super cool, thank you.
There's so many things I
want to talk to you about
but the first thing I
have to do this first,
like I have to understand how
you could possibly compete
in the Olympics in the same
year that you co-wrote,
co-directed and starred
in a feature film.
And I feel like it's so insane.
And what's interesting about you
and myself and our
different backgrounds
is that I think there
are very few people,
an average person can
kind of understand
what it takes to be an Olympian
or what it takes to
make a feature film,
but I'm deeply connected
to both of those things.
I wasn't an Olympian, but I
trained with a lot of Olympians.
As an entertainment lawyer,
I've been deeply involved
in the production of many
independent feature films.
And I have a very tactile
sense of what's required
to execute at the highest
level to realize those dreams.
Each in their own right
are feats of impossibility,
but to accomplish both in the
same year is so astounding.
Like I just can't even
wrap my head around it.
It's such an magnificent
accomplishment.
- Thank you, well-
- And to do it well
like the movie,
I mean, I love "Tracktown",
I love "Olympic Dreams"
and for "Tracktown" to
be your first feature
that you and Jeremy did
together, I was really amazed.
- I really appreciate that.
And I think sometimes
our willingness
to stretch ourselves
and try something
that we've never done before
is made more powerful by
the fact that we don't know
what it will really take,
but once we're committed
I think people like us will
we'll do what it takes.
And I was noticing,
I know this isn't,
I don't know if I
can say this on here,
but this is a new studio, right?
This is a new setup and you
have a shower in your bathroom.
- I know that we just finished
construction on that yesterday.
- And is it so that you
might train and shower
and then do some
of your work here?
- 100%.
- So that the idea that
you like have created,
you've created a life around
being able to transition
from one thing that you're
doing in a day to the other.
And I think that's practical
but there's also
something mental
about shifting gears and
being able to hyper-focus
with any one of your
tasks in any given day
and then being able
to consciously shift
to the next one.
And I think some of
the the misconception
that people might have
when they look the things
that I've done on
paper in any given year
is that I'm doing them
all at the same time.
And the truth is that I'm
trying to do one of those things
really well in any given moment
and then excellently
transition to the next task.
And I think that in that year,
it kept me healthy as an
athlete to end practice
at a certain time and to not
have practice last all day,
because as you and I know,
you can run for several hours
but you can't run all day.
But some people let that happen
whether it's mentally
or physically.
And so in some ways
ending practice
and just worrying about how
are we gonna fund this movie
was a blessing to my
Olympic trajectory as well.
- Because you couldn't just
sit and stew and obsess
about things that you
don't have control over.
Like it allowed you to
shift gears and stay fresh
with both things because
you had other pursuits
outside of just
that singular focus?
- Yeah, and it even
simplified running
because if I thought
about how challenging
it was going to be
to do this workout,
I could also have the
perspective of how simple it is
that I just need to
keep putting one foot
in front of the other when
it felt like so complicated
to try to put together
a feature film.
So I think the feature
film, people dynamics,
you know what it takes
to put a movie together
is so different than what it
takes to just keep running
when you're in a mile repeat.
And likewise, the pain
of doing that mile repeat
or doing multiple was very
painful compared to the ease
of sitting on a couch
and making phone calls
or writing a script,
which is hard,
but it's not like my body
hurts while I'm doing it.
So I think they were Tweedledee
and Tweedledum to each
other, just playful.
- (indistinct) writer
so overwhelming.
There must have been
moments where you just felt
like I'm climbing a mountain
that is double the
size of Everest.
- Yeah, it felt hard.
I have a great partner too.
You know, like I do
have Jeremy with me
and I was never pulling
all nighters while my goal,
my number one goal was
to go to the Olympics.
So I think part of it, and
perhaps you can relate,
is knowing what is the
priority in any given moment
and always knowing
what my North star was,
and then everything
needs to fall under that.
So like I am gonna sleep
at least eight hours a night
and that's non-negotiable,
even if we need to
stay up late editing,
there's a time when
I need to stop.
So maybe those
boundaries are more clear
because I knew what the priority
one was and priority two,
but it was stressful.
But it was stressful
in like a thrilling way
because I was playing
a game, running,
and I was making a movie.
- And also no one's ever done
anything like that before,
which is kind of exhilarating
and intimidating
I would suspect.
And I'm sure you get the
balanced question all the time.
Like, how do you
balance your life?
And I hate that I don't look
at life in that context.
It just seems confusing to me.
Like, it seems my sense is
that it's more with you.
It's more about synergy.
Like, are these things in
synergy with each other?
Do they feed off of each other?
Do each one of these things
make me better at the other one?
- Do you feel like
you're thriving, right?
It's like more of a feeling
and how do you answer it
when people ask
you that question?
- I mean, I used to feel,
I used to feel guilt and shame
because my life is
not really balanced
in that traditional sense.
And I would strive to make
it fit into those buckets.
And at some point I just
let go of that whole thing
and, you know,
look, in the macro,
and I'm sure this is
the case with yourself,
in the macro, your life
is very much imbalanced
but you're shifting gears
between intense focus
on different things that
give your life meaning
and make you excited when
you wake up in the morning.
but to the average person,
on a day-to-day basis,
it would appear that you're
very much out of balance.
- Yes, okay, now I
feel like I understand
what you're getting at
because there were
people during that time
who were like I think you and
Jeremy should take a break
and go camping this weekend.
Like, I think you
guys need a night off
or like I think you need, I
think you should, I think...
And that was like...
You know, I was at an
age where it was like,
I felt a little weird
about it, I was like,
I know I'm living in Oregon
and there's so
much great camping,
but all I want to do is
work on these projects.
Like, I was so happy
being so overflowing
with what I was doing.
And I feel like what
you're saying is similarly,
you live to work but
your work is your choice
and your work is your passion.
And so it's your pleasure to
have this bubbling cauldron
that someone might look at
and not think is healthy.
- Yeah, I mean, there's that,
but it's also the intensity
that you bring to whatever
it is you're doing.
Like if it's an
ultra endurance race
or you training for the Olympics
or trying to execute
on a feature film
or me doing what I do here,
I get joy out of
being totally immersed
in whatever it is
that I'm doing.
And I'm not effective unless
I can say no to other things
and pop things out so
that I can give my best.
But that means that
other things in my life
that are important to me
aren't getting adequate
amount of attention
on that particular day.
So the gear shifting
is important,
such that everything in
my life that I care about
is attended to properly.
It just doesn't happen
on an hour-to-hour
or day-to-day basis necessarily.
- Yeah. Yep.
- Yeah, right, I
know you feel it,
your volume on that, right?
- Yeah.
- I feel like when I
watched "Tracktown",
your erstwhile boyfriend in
the movie was sort of a proxy
for the people who are saying,
take a break or go camping.
And I found that movie, like
it's so heartfelt and authentic
and beautifully realized
in so many ways,
but it was also very
stressful for me
to watch that movie-
- Really?
- Because my sense is that
you were trying to craft
an alternate universe in
which you weren't somebody
who has many different interests
and allocates your energy
across a variety of disciplines,
but to stand in the
shoes of that person
who is all in a 100%
on just that one thing,
and you're tiptoeing
outside of that, you know,
on the precipice of trying
to qualify for the Olympics.
And I was like,
just wait two days,
like can't you just go back
into your altitude tent and rest
until like Thursday or
whatever day it was,
like, your race is tomorrow.
- Yes, well, that's funny
because so many people
who don't know me think that
"Tracktown" is a documentary.
And I was like, well, first
of all, that would mean
a number of different things
if it was actually
a documentary,
like that we caught me losing
my virginity on camera somehow
and things like that.
(both laughing)
Which is not-
- No,
people didn't actually
think that, right?
- No, we've had that.
- Really?
- We've also had people
who did not believe
that Plum as a
character was real.
And these are people who are
outside the running world
like really prestigious,
like film advisers.
We were in a
Sundance lab with it
and some people
just didn't believe
that someone like
that could exist.
Someone who had never
kissed a boy at age 21
and that's very real.
- It's incredibly real.
- To you, but to the
world, she isn't known.
And that was part of the reason
why I wanted to
put her on camera
and to say that this
person does exist.
She's a patchwork quilt
of people that I know
and experiences I've
had, but she could exist.
And those are the
types of characters
that I'm interested in
putting in my movies,
is like the characters
that I know are real,
the world doesn't know them yet,
and these scenarios could exist.
- Yeah, I know that girl, I've
been around a lot of people
very much like that.
Have you read David
Epstein's book "Range"?
- Yes.
- Yeah, so I've been thinking
a lot about that book
in the context of your story
because for people who don't
know his thesis is essentially
that people who are
super high performers
by and large defy
conventional wisdom.
They're not the tiger
woods or the plums
who go all in at a very early
age on one singular pursuit,
but rather there are
people who dabble
in lots of different things
before they finally end up
like kind of deciding
what their lane is.
And you're somebody who
is a beautiful case study
of that thesis and Plum
is of the 10,000 hour,
you know, Malcolm
Gladwell kind of rule.
And I say conventional wisdom
because there is this idea,
like if you wanna excel
at that highest level
you have to be that
plum-type individual.
And in truth more often
than not, it's not the case.
And the people that are like
the plums end up burning out.
Like you see this individual
who's not fully emotionally
realized, right?
And her strength, which is her
focus, is also her weakness.
It's her blind spot
that's holding her back
from performing at
the highest level,
because she still has so
much to learn and grow
because she's so siloed
in her life experience.
- Yeah, it, it reminds
me of this advice we got
from our college coach
when I was at Dartmouth
and we were going to a
national championships.
It was like the first
one I'd ever been to.
I was like a junior. It
was for a relay team.
And he turns to us,
this is Mark Coogan,
he was also an Olympian.
And he was like, this isn't
an Ivy League Reference,
but he was like, just
remember that you're smart
and you can think and
that's a strength too.
And I think he felt bad
because some of us were writing
our final papers on the bus,
like we were balancing a lot.
But I think what he really
meant was that we had
some perspective to
bring into that race,
whatever that meant, and
to use that as a strength.
And I have felt that in races
where just being able
to think critically
or zoom out a little or have
some perspective does help.
And I think that's
what you're saying
about like a character like
Plum, where that hyper-focus,
that hyper-focus is
really noble and useful.
But the range, the bringing
in people dynamics,
understanding the world
in a different way
can be a strength too.
- Yeah, it's a
balancing act, right?
Because you do have to
be all in in some way,
but you have to provide that
room to be a human being.
- Especially in a
sport like running
which has to grow with you.
Like probably all
sports are like that,
but running as much as any
has got to evolve
as you're evolving.
And I think it's the people
who try to keep it what it was
or what they think it
should be that become bitter
which is just not
the word we want.
- Right, but by cutting
this unique path
that you've carved for yourself,
I would imagine along the way,
there's been a lot of people
who are sort of naysayers
or trying to dissuade you
or saying you're
taking on too much
or why don't you
just do it this way?
- For sure, I mean,
from the very minute
that I graduated college,
there were certain opportunities
that would have either,
there were opportunities that
would have actually blended
my storytelling and my
running goals into one
much earlier than I was ready.
So we're getting a
little esoteric here,
but basically, when I first
graduated from college,
I wanted to be a filmmaker,
an actress, and an Olympian.
But I knew that until I
had created those platforms
and had those
stand on their own,
they wouldn't be
able to come together
in the way that I feel
that they have now.
And so I made certain choices
where I think I was
being encouraged
to be the filmmaker
runner right away.
And I needed to make choices
for my running career
that would set me up
to be a great athlete
independent of the film career.
And I needed to make
choices as a creative
that would make a great movie
regardless of if I was
a great athlete or not.
- Right, I mean, this
is something that you
and Jeremy talked about with
Dave Chang on his podcast,
which I really enjoyed
that conversation,
but the idea being that
your filmmaking success
cannot be contingent
upon name recognition
around you as an athlete
and your performances have
to stand on their own.
And you've done that,
like you are, you know,
you are the athlete that you are
and it has nothing to
do with your filmmaking.
And you don't have
to know who you are
to watch these movies
and enjoy them.
It has nothing to do
with your, you know,
how fast you can
run 10,000 meters
or a marathon or anything else.
- Thank you, and maybe
that speaks to range.
I think those people
who are seeking
the range of experiences,
I would hope that all those
people are still seeking
to seek the best of
those worlds, right?
Like I don't know, like
I don't love cupcakes.
I like them, but
if I'm gonna go,
I wanna find like
the best cupcakes.
You know, I wanna like go
to the peaks of these worlds
because there's something
to be learned from people
and communities that are
chasing the best of any world.
And that's why I listened
to David Chang's podcasts
because I like how invested
he is in his craft.
And I know I can learn from him
even though I'm not
in the food industry.
- Right, it's the mindset,
it's the approach.
It's the respect for the craft,
the attention to
detail, the quality,
all of those things
whether you're an athlete,
a filmmaker, or a writer or
a chef, they're all related,
they're all relevant
to pursuing something
and trying to be
excellent at it.
- And I think that for me,
that comes from like a
really melancholic place
if I really think about it
and I've never thought
about it this way,
but I think that
I always wanted...
Like I did not have a
mom, I lost her young.
And I think I always wanted that
or was curious
what that could be
with full awareness that I
could never have it really truly
how I would want it,
but I did know that I
could have everything else.
And I talk about this in the
book as the mentor buffet,
it's what I call it, but
I think what I meant was,
well, I'm just gonna go chase
the best of every other world
and try to patchwork it,
quilt it into something
that can fill that need
for that keystone mentor
as best that I can.
So, I think it comes from that.
Like, I truly think it was
like a survival thing of,
I can't have the very best
of the very singular
thing I would like,
but I'm gonna chase and
shamelessly draw from
and dip myself into every other
world if that interests me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
I mean, in the book,
you did a beautiful job
of kind of underscoring
or illustrating this
void in your life.
And I wanna go back and
hear more about this
of not having a mom
and like your hypervigilance,
whenever you were in a situation
in which daughters
were with moms,
whether it was girl scouts
or the feeding of the ducks
and all of these experiences
where you looked at it
almost as something exotic
that you couldn't quite
emotionally connect with, right?
And that tracks like all
the way through your life
even to the point where
you're at the Olympics
and you go to get
like a make-over
and that experience
of having that person,
have you comb your
hair and all of that,
like it was so foreign to you
because you didn't grow up
with a mom who taught
you these things.
- Yes, and I think it
takes a certain muscle
to feel like the
world is a reservoir
that gives rather than takes,
and that we all have a
choice to make about that.
Whether we see the
world that way or not,
but if we can see it as
something where we're allowed
to get things and soak it in,
then we can get it
anywhere we look.
And I think that wears off for
a lot of people eventually,
like you feel like I'm
formed as a person.
I now will create
content and put it out
rather than take it in anymore,
and that's fine, we don't need
to take in from everywhere.
But the world is remarkable
and there is a lot
that we can get from it
even in adulthood if
we see it that way.
- Yeah, that's so true.
Well, let's take it back.
You're growing up in Berkeley.
Let's go all the way
to the beginning.
- [Alexi] Okay.
- So, walk me through
you as a young girl,
four years old.
- Well, I was born in Berkeley
and grew up on an
Island called Alameda.
It was more like a
peninsula Bay Farm Island.
- I've never heard Alameda
referred to as an Island,
but yes, I guess it is.
- I think it's like
the Island city,
but then Bay Farm
was at peninsula
which is essentially the Oakland
Airport it's right there.
And that was a safe Island
to be, like you could walk
with your friends to the
ice cream shop as we did,
and your parents
would generally think
you were going to be okay.
But yeah, so when I was young,
the first like four or
five years of my life,
it coincided with my
mom's like really intense,
you know, downward spiral.
She was manic bipolar
and I think my birth
really catalyzed
a really tough turn for her.
She was addicted to
painkillers. She had scoliosis.
So this was in the 90s,
so there was a lot
of over prescription,
I think, of painkillers.
And so she was addicted to
them and she was very smart
and able to like obtain
them in any way possible,
which now my dad and I were
able to actually have a laugh
about when I read him the book,
I read it to him out loud,
which was a really, really fun,
it was a really meaningful
weekend, but he opened up a lot
and she was very
scrappy about her drugs
and she got them.
And she was depressed
and she was getting help
that I now understand would
not have helped anybody
in her position.
And that I only understood
in the last year or two
discovering paperwork
from her care in Berkeley.
But she was in and
out of our life
'cause she was in
institutions or drug rehab.
And so I never had
that relationship
with her where I don't
remember really touching her.
And that has always been
a strange thing for me,
an obsession maybe of like
just what it would be like
to be embraced like that-
- Right.
Then the one recollection that
you have of physical contact
with her was her giving
you her cigarette
when you're like this
tiny little girl.
- Oh, I'll never forget that.
I mean, and it's so...
When I wrote that
too, I was afraid
that people might read it and
think she was a bad person
or like a bad mom.
And I think that's why a book
is a really important medium
as compared to like a
one off social media post
or other forms of sharing,
which is fragmented.
And I wanted to
write that in a way
where perhaps you didn't
understand her fully,
'cause at that age
I didn't either.
And that's why the book...
You know, I tried to
emotionally progressive
rather than just linearly.
- Right.
- So she was smoking a
cigarette and she did often,
and it was just me and her.
I rarely remember her
giving me attention
but she did in this moment and
she offered me her cigarette
and I smoked it and I was-
(both laughing)
- It's so amazing.
- Well, it so, you know,
the world is-
- It's heartbreaking.
- Well, yeah, but
what's heartbreaking is,
or what's cool about it and
what's been tough about it
is that I realized much later
that all I've looked
for ever since then
is that feeling of
somebody I admire so much
sharing something with me.
And it like means so much
'cause it makes me feel
like that again, you know?
- Well, her condition
was very acute.
She's in and out of
these institutions
and when she would come home
seemingly in a state
of relative fitness
so that she could
be with her family,
everybody's on pins and needles,
all the attention
is on her 24/7.
And it's interesting
how that blueprint
gets imprinted on you.
And then, you know, as a kind
of survivor of this trauma,
you then become this
person who is like,
I want the attention
on me, you know,
how can I get the attention?
How can I be seen
in a certain way?
And so many of the pursuits
that you've gone after
are kind of like,
well, what do you do?
You make movies or you
become an Olympian,
that way it's undeniable, right?
Everybody's gonna have
to pay attention to you.
- Yes, it was a completely
effective and unhealthy pursuit
of chasing-
- And awesome.
Like it's messy and
complicated, right?
- But I was chasing, I
think for so many years,
external solutions to
an internal problem,
like it was so
effective though, right?
I was like, I can put
myself through as much pain
as humanly possible
in the good way.
Like 'cause I
consider running pain
or the vulnerability of acting
with someone as good pain.
I was like, I will go
to the world's edge
in the game of good
pain and just watch me.
And it has been
tremendously powerful,
like I can go to the
end of good pain.
- And what does that,
you know, diving deeper
into the relationship with
pain, like how does that act
as a therapeutic for
some of these issues?
- Well, it's not the
feeling of pain is therapy,
it's the feeling,
it's the feeling of
mattering that I get
as a result of
enduring that pain.
And that's not been an entirely,
I think, healthy thing to chase.
To chase, I want to matter
because I didn't feel
like I mattered enough
for my mom to stay.
I now understand
that not to be true
but for so much of my life,
I think until the Olympics,
I thought that my
mission in life would be
to not be like her,
to be as far from
her as possible
which I saw as being
successful and happy.
And the ways that I
might've chased that
were chasing these
external goals.
- Right, but through
running, did you, you know,
there's something
cathartic about running
and that relationship
with pain that does work
to kind of self emotional
wounds in a certain way,
like in a kind of
meditative way,
like it's almost like
performing an exorcism,
you know, of unconscious
things that are going on
in your awareness
that are traumatic.
- Yeah, that's how
you feel about it?
- Yeah, I do.
Yeah, I do. Not for you though.
- No, no, I think I do too.
I think that I feel that
as long as I'm in the
territory of good pain,
then that's a good
application of myself.
And I think that she could have
been chasing good pain too.
She just didn't have
the right mentorship.
Like she just didn't
have the guidance
to go there instead
of there, right?
But running does
feel like that to me.
It feels like a really...
You're on the outermost
limits of yourself mentally
and physically with running.
And so it is, you are dancing
on that edge and it's good.
- So much of your
life was premised
on differentiating
yourself from your mom
like out of a fear that you
might follow in her footsteps
in a certain way.
And I would imagine that you
felt like you had escaped that
in some way, but as
the OP-Doc shows,
and as you talk about in
your book, like, nonetheless,
you have this experience
with depression
in the aftermath of
the Olympics, you
know, most acutely,
it must've been terrifying
when that was visited upon you.
You must've thought
like, oh my goodness,
am I going to end
up like my mother?
- Yeah, it was.
I mean, when I started having...
First of all I didn't
have the vocabulary
that I tried to
share in the OP-Doc.
I didn't have that vocabulary
when I started experiencing
these symptoms.
So I was in total
denial that I was sick
because I didn't understand
that your brain can get
injured just like your knee.
I just didn't understand that.
And so I was of the mindset as
I had always been in my life
that I needed to
keep pressing forward
and fix all on my own, whatever
it was that I was feeling
to the point where
I wasn't sleeping
but I tried to force
myself to sleep.
And, you know, it's called
falling asleep for a reason.
You have to it happen.
- Being a good type A athlete,
you're trying to know whirl
everything into existence.
- And then I started to have
these even darker thoughts,
and that's when I felt
like I understood my mom
in a way that I never
wanted to understand her.
Like, you have these
thoughts that you wanna die
and I don't think you
really want to want to die
but the thoughts say otherwise,
and that's when you're sick.
And it was terrifying because
I've always been afraid
my whole life for the moment
that might happen to me.
And where that fear came from
was I have a photo book of her
when she was like teenager.
And she looked really happy.
And I was like, there's no way.
I just don't believe that
this 16-year old knows
what's gonna happen to her.
And that was so scary 'cause
I was like, is it gonna...
Am I a ticking time bomb?
Does it just happen to people?
And you know, her brother
took his own life.
Like it runs deep in her family.
So I just knew that
there was a possibility,
and then when it did,
but before I understood
that there was a
way to get better,
I thought that that
was just my fate.
That like, it now happened to me
and because the narrative
I was told about her
was she just had to go,
like she just was so
sick that she had to go.
And I was like, well
I guess I'm so sick
that maybe I have to go
'cause I don't know
what else there is.
And that's so embarrassing
honestly to share
because I don't feel
that way anymore,
but I didn't understand.
And I think it's sad that even
someone who was susceptible
to these things, you know,
my family history
was public, right?
There was no prehab, if you
will, if you wanna call like,
if we wanna use
this body comparison
of the brain is a body part.
I had no prehab, I had no
preparation to deal with this.
And it wasn't until my dad,
because of his experience
with my mom made me get help
that I met a doctor, Dr. Pam,
who told me very
simply that I was sick
and that my brain
had a scratch on it.
And that it could get injured,
like any other body part
but it could also heal
and suddenly everything like,
it literally turned
around in a day.
I wasn't happy, but I believed
that I could be on
a path to healing
and that I could commit to it
just like I would
in Olympic dream.
- Did it also provide you
with a little more empathy
for your mom?
- Oh, 100%.
My relationship with her has
been such a rollercoaster
where I didn't know how
she died for a long time.
So I felt sorry for her
'cause I used to think
she died from smoking.
And then I was really angry-
- You didn't find out
until like seventh grade or
something like that, right?
- And it was Amanda,
our dear friend, Amanda,
who loves you, (laughs),
Who-
- She should be here today.
She's saving lives.
- Next time Amanda.
- She's saving lives.
So we were in middle school
and there's this day,
where everyone was
supposed to make tombstones
for people that they,
cardboard tombstones,
people they knew to
have died of smoking.
And I wrote my mom's
name, felt very brave,
you know those moments
in your life where like,
today's the day where I'm brave.
So it was brave and I
wrote her name down,
and it was in retrospect
really embarrassing
because that's not how she
died and everybody else knew,
but I didn't know.
And it's in the yearbook.
It's in my seventh
grade year book,
this picture, it was
on no smoking day.
Her name is there.
- Oh, my goodness.
- And everyone else wrote
Walt Disney for some reason.
And then Amanda pulled
me aside and she told me
that her mom told her she
should tell me the truth.
And it was really a
gift that she told me
'cause it's good to know.
- Yeah, but you
must've been off too
that you were the last
person to find out.
- You know, I've never been
able to like truly be mad
at my dad for anything
relating to my mom.
Like I was angry
in the preteen way,
but I wasn't angry
in the real way.
And I was never gonna tell him.
Like I remember I was like,
I'm not gonna tell him
that I know because
clearly this is, I just...
And there's a chapter
in the book called
"Dad's Said That's
About Just This,"
where you're just more angry
at the circumstance
that he's in in general,
it feels unfair.
So I wasn't angry at
him for not telling me,
just like I'm not angry at
him for any of the strange
or unusual parenting
that he's done.
- Well, your dad was in
an impossible situation.
And he rose to the
occasion like a champ.
I mean, there's things that
he did to like raise you
and your brother
are quite amazing.
And I wanna get into
that in a minute,
but on this subject
of depression
and elite athletics.
We're in a moment right now
where we're having conversations
that we should have
had a long time ago.
It's very much in the kind
of mainstream parlance.
I recently had Caroline Burckle
on the show, an Olympian,
who has her version
of your experience.
We've talked about the "Weight
of Gold" that documentary,
and kind of what Michael
Phelps is doing right now
to talk about these issues.
So there's an openness, I
think, to this discussion
but I think what makes your
story a little bit different
and unique is that most of these
athletes are so singularly.
They're like plump, like
they're just on this track
and then they either make
the Olympics or they don't,
and then they're faced with
this existential crisis
about what they're
supposed to do
with the rest of their life and
they're only 24, 30 at most.
But you're unique in
that you already not only
had a complete grip on what
it is that you wanted to do
outside of sport, you're
already fully immersed in it
and successful in it.
So that transition away
from athletic performance
into creative pursuits,
that path was already
being blazed by you.
And yet that was not enough
for you to escape
this experience,
which whether genetic or
whatever it is still visited you
and was still very difficult.
- Well, perhaps that's
like the epiphany
that some people have
when they realize
that running hurts for
everyone, no matter what.
Like when I talked to
people and they realized
that running still hurts
me, they're amazed.
They're like, wait, it hurts
you just like it hurts me?
I'm like, it does hurt me.
I just have a different
relationship now with pain.
And I see it as more of a
sensation, not a threat.
But I think the thought
that anyone is immune
to this kind of scratch on
your brain or these illnesses
is just like that
misconception where it's like,
no actually anxiety
about the future
or a fundamental
misunderstanding about the brain
or whatever it is that leads
to these mental illnesses
can happen to everyone.
And to think, it's like how
growing up is hard for everyone.
Like whether you're extremely
privileged or challenge,
no matter what I think
in different ways,
growing up is always
gonna be challenging.
And so probably to
assign a godlike maturity
to someone who's at
the top of their game
is not the right thing, right?
Like we might be
really, really mature.
Our bodies might be
totally peaked on paper.
We might be doing great,
but there's still,
we all have to go through
the emotional maturity
in growing up and if
we haven't been given
the vocabulary to see our
lives a different way,
or to see those challenges
when they come differently,
then we're gonna,
we might mess up.
- Right, right, right, I
mean, it's that identity
that you shoulder as an Olympian
but also the projection that
everybody places on you, right?
Like you're supposed
to be immune
from these sorts
of things, right?
So then of course that
makes it more difficult
for the person who's
suffering to actually reckon
with what's happening because
there's guilt and shame
and why is this happening to me?
I have no reason to feel the
way that I'm feeling right now.
- For sure, when you feel
like the world sees you
a completely different
way than you see yourself,
there's nothing
more mind-blowingly
difficult than that.
It's so weird. It's so strange.
- And then to talk about
it feels indulgent.
Like you're gonna burden
somebody with your like,
you know, Madam
Olympian over here
with your little
depression problem.
- For sure.
(host laughing)
But again, I think that's
abstracting it to like...
We are in a place where
we can accept, I think,
as a world that elite
athletes and high-achievers
can have these mental injuries,
these mental illnesses.
But I think the most
important thing now is like,
what do we do about them?
And that was something
that I find that sometimes,
you know, we point fingers
at the pinnacle institutions
that we're chasing but
actually I truly think
that this kind of education
or shift has to
happen much younger
and on a more universal level,
not just at those pinnacles.
- So what would that look
like if you were in charge
and could put those
things in place?
- Well, let's look at body,
the way we've
approached the body
and like how that's
progressed over the last,
let's say 10 years.
Like 10 years ago,
I don't think my dad
or my friend's little
sister would have seen a PT
for their body without
having an injury.
Meaning like regularly
take care of their body.
And so just looking at that
world, we've come a long way
to accepting that our
body is something not only
elite athletes
should take care of,
but everybody
should take care of.
And that we should take care
of it before it's a problem,
ideally, if you are able to
have that kind of support
and it's not...
There's just like systems and
you can get that kind of help
if you can and need it, right?
And I think with mental health,
comparing it to
healing an injury
is so simple to me and
makes so much sense.
So what it would look like
to me is accepting honestly
that our brain is a body
part and it can get injured.
And when it gets injured, just
like when we break our leg
or feel something
strange in our leg,
we have no shame about
sharing that something's off
and we get help and we
know where to get help.
And it's either built into
the system that we're in,
like a team might have a physio,
they might have a
psychologist too.
Or someone can refer you
to their favorite physio
or their favorite psycho.
Like there's just
more accessibility,
just like there is
in like the PT world.
And then we get that help and
we are as kind to ourselves
as we are hard on ourselves
knowing that it's not
gonna resolve overnight.
Like nobody is demanding
that somebody's broken
leg heal tomorrow.
And so why are we demanding
that somebody's
depression heal tomorrow?
- Because it's uncomfortable
for us to talk about, right?
We wanna pretend that it doesn't
exist or there's shame or-
- Right, because it's invisible.
But if we think about
it more like an injury,
like no one can see your
torn hamstring either
but they know that it's
there if you say it
and they believe it's there.
So if we just see it as
more of a physical injury,
which it is, then I think
it becomes a little less
subjective and a
little more objective.
- Right, well, I also think
in the athlete context
that at a university
every athletic department
has a whole like complex
around physical therapy.
But the mind is only beginning
to be addressed in that world.
And it's so important
we're just now beginning
to really understand
how critical it is
that our emotional
wellbeing is attended to
and needs to be rehabbed
from time to time
in the same way
that your joints do.
- Totally. I think that's it.
I can only speak
to my experience
but that change of
perspective saved my life.
Like it allowed me
to buy into a process
and believe in it and
believe that it could work.
And I remember being told
you're going to be sad every day
for a long time.
And it was not unlike
hearing when I broke my foot,
your foot is gonna be broken
every day for a long time.
It's gonna take
12 weeks to heal.
But it will be healing.
And I started to
think about myself
as like a crockpot, like
a soup where, you know,
so I was told that I
was going to be sad
and that I should rather
focus on my actions
and that those were the
only things I could control.
And I thought about
myself as that soup
where I was gonna put in actions
and I wasn't gonna know in
what ratio, like, you know,
how much did medication help
versus cognitive
behavioral therapy
versus finally getting
the sleep I needed
versus simply waiting
for a period of time
versus going for walks.
Like you never know
what kind of ratios,
what the perfect ratio is,
but you do know the
soup is cooking.
You're putting in ingredients,
you're stirring, you're waiting
and it will become soup.
- Right, and in the
meantime, just being told
like you're gonna feel this way
allows you to be in acceptance
rather than beating yourself up
because you woke up again,
it didn't feel good.
- You don't have the secondary
emotion of being offended
by the sadness as much.
You almost are like, you
wake up with the sadness.
Like it's, you know,
I don't have a child
but I think about like,
if a baby's crying
and you're at the grocery
store, the baby's crying
but you still gotta to
get the milk, you know?
So I think it in
that way sometimes
where you almost have a
sense of humor about it
or at least some levity to
understand that it's there,
it will be there for a while
and you're in the process
of making it go away.
- It almost sounds like
stepping outside of it,
like not self
identifying with it.
It's this thing. It's not me.
- Yes, it's this-
- Entity and sadness.
- Yeah, it's your sadness.
And I was told that
actions change first,
then thoughts, then
feelings, and in that order.
And that was another life
saving rule basically
because what I've observed
from my mom was that
her caretakers were trying
to force the feelings
and she was trying to force
the feelings to change.
And we can't.
They follow our thoughts,
which follow our actions.
- Right, I always say
mood follows action.
- Perfect, right?
- Right.
So you get to the
other side of this,
what is your daily regimen now
for kind of maintaining
your mental wellbeing.
- Yeah, okay, that's
a great question.
First of all, I found it
very difficult to find
like psychiatric,
psychological care in general.
It was hard when needed it.
I had to ask for favors
and that sucked honestly
that you can't get it as readily
as you might be able to see a PT
and I've still found
it challenging.
I still found it labyrinthian
to find good care,
but I've found like
continued support.
I work with the
psychiatrist here
to just make sure I check in.
And also, I work with a team
it's not just sports psychology,
it's like psychology.
I work with a woman
named Natalie Pacetti
and she's helped me
like continue to unbound
some of the childhood personal
laws that might be driving me
in an unhealthy way and
might be limiting me.
So this is like an
ever unfolding thing
and I'm working on it,
but on a day-to-day level,
I think I'm also
monitoring myself,
and so I take a little
bit more seriously.
If there's a night where I'm
like restless and can't sleep,
that's a moment to
pause and figure out
like what is keeping
me up at night?
Because prior I was
like plowing ahead
and never not slowing down to
wonder why that was happening.
And then there's this one
tool that my physio gave me
that I think is the
coolest thing in the world,
which is, can I share?
- Yeah.
- I feel like I'm talking a lot.
- No, come on, this is
what we're here to do.
- This is so cool.
- I wanna here this.
- Okay, so I had this physio,
he is from Japan.
I was working with him,
his name's Cudi in LA.
I was having like some
symptoms in my hip one time.
And instead of like looking
at my hip right away,
he asked me about my face.
And he was like, "have
you noticed anything?"
'Cause I was like, is my hip
broken? Like what's going on?
And he was like, "okay back up,
last week when this started,
did you notice
anything in your face?"
And I actually had like
a small red discoloration
under my eye that was abnormal,
almost like a
little mini sunburn.
And he was like, okay, cool.
So you have the most
nerves in your face,
your stomach, and your hands.
And when your body is
starting to get overloaded,
whether you're stressed
out or it's over-training,
like the cells only no effort.
So he was basically saying,
when you start overdoing it,
your body wants you to succeed.
So it will give you signs
that tell you to pause.
And he told me that I needed
to pay better attention
to my face because this
was not a broken hip.
This was just a nervous
system overload,
and my nerves, once
your face is ignored
will start shutting down
parts of your body for a bit,
and then eventually, you know,
it'll keep shutting you down
because it wants
to preserve you.
So from there forward,
I started paying
close attention to...
I have wonderful Greek skin
and I don't get a lot of acne.
So when I get a pimple, it
might mean a day off, literally.
And for other people, it
might be a canker sore
or an eye twitch, or just
whatever is abnormal for you
on your face, I suppose,
or your stomach,
but the face is just
a really obvious one,
it just means that you're
starting to get overloaded.
And so what I'm doing now is
trying to pay better attention
to the signs, the very
first signs of overdoing it
so that I don't get to
the point of not sleeping
for three months.
- Right, that's fascinating.
- Isn't it great?
- Yeah. That's very cool.
I've never thought of that.
I mean, it's sort of
kind of a acupuncturist,
kind of ayurvedic way
of looking at things,
like everything you know,
your body is this organism
that's trying to always find
its balance point, right?
And when something's
out of balance,
there will be some kind of
symptom that might show up
in a very unpredictable
and different way
than you might suspect
that has nothing to do
with whatever is actually
wrong right itself, right?
It's a little glimmer, a glimpse
into paying more attention.
- And that the body wants
you to succeed, right?
It's not, I feel like
so often we're like,
my body hates me today
and it's like your
body never hates you.
That can't be true, right?
(host laughing)
- I hope not.
And so maybe we
shift our, you know,
maybe we shift to feeling
like our body's rooting for us
and it's telling us in all
the languages that it knows.
- It can be mad at us.
- Yeah, it could be
frustrated, right?
But always trying to help.
- Right, that's a
very optimistic, cool
way to look at it.
- Yeah, and I've shared that
with like elite athlete
friends, and it's really,
when they think
back to an injury,
they can recall, like I had
a canker sore that week.
And now we in my small
satellite teammate community,
we pay better
attention to our faces.
- That's a good practice.
Well, let's go
back a little bit.
You know, let's talk about
you growing up with your dad
back to the kind of David
Epstein "Range" thing.
Like you weren't a track
standout from the get go
or you were playing all
different kinds of sports.
You were like a soccer
standout originally, right?
And dabbling in track but
then you were forced to quit
the track team or you got
fired from the track team
because you wouldn't
go all in on that
and let go of the other sports?
- Correct, there was
leadership at my high school
that in running, we needed
to not do anything else.
There were other sports
where it felt like athletes,
particularly male
athletes were embraced
for being multi-sport athletes,
but I was definitely not
embraced in that way.
And because I was not
willing to, at 15 years old,
quit soccer and
student government
and all these other things,
I was like de facto kicked
off the running team.
And I was good.
I was like one of the
top runners in the State
but I didn't love
running at that age
because I didn't love the team.
There was no team environment
which is my favorite
part about sports.
It didn't feel positive.
The coach, it wasn't a
positive environment.
So I naturally did not feel
like I could specialize.
- Did he tell you
that you had to quit
student government too?
- Yes, so I was kicked
off the team twice.
The first time was
because of soccer
and the second-
- Did they overlap in seasons?
- Yes, there were some
soccer practices overlapping
with the running season.
It was club soccer.
- Right.
- So they do overlap.
And then, the next
year, my senior year,
I was like, okay, maybe I
won't do the soccer overlap
but I was vice
president of my class
and I wasn't allowed
to do that either.
And that was hard as
well because what...
I feel that today that would
have been like a New York times
piece in and of itself-
- Right.
I mean, it's high school track.
I mean, come on.
- I agree. I agree.
And I was committed, I
was there when I could be,
but I was trying to
like be a whole person.
And I don't think any 15
year old should be told
to quit anything, you know.
And I just remember feeling
like I was a bad kid
and I didn't like that.
I didn't like how
shameful it felt
to do what I was doing.
- But at the same time,
you've demonstrated
healthy boundaries.
Like there's a self-awareness
and a sense of self
that you demonstrated
as a young person.
Because I suspect like if
I was in that situation,
and I was showing promise
as a track athlete,
I probably would have
just done what the coach
wanted me to do and
quit everything else
and gone all in on that.
- Well, you might have, and
then you might have not had
the joy to last you through
10 more years of training
or maybe-
- Right, well I'm not saying
it would have been
the right decision.
I'm just thinking, like, I
don't know that my boundaries
would have been much more
porous and influenced
by people of authority.
You're somebody who knew
yourself well enough to say
these other things
are important to me,
I'm not gonna do with
this guy wants me to do.
- Yeah, I've always like
been really unable do things
that are against my gut.
Like, it feels so bad.
Feels bad, and my
gut is really loud.
- So like a Greek thing?
- Yeah, the Greek
gut. It's so loud.
We have the loudest gut.
- My microbiome is very vocal.
- I don't know, it
didn't feel right.
Even though there wasn't like
a bigger national discussion
about it at that time, there
wasn't even social media,
so nobody would have
known about this,
I think I knew that it wasn't
quite like a healthy thing.
- So obviously you do
really well in school.
You get into
Dartmouth, you know,
going all the way to the
other coast for college
and you end up running there,
but what's amazing is that you,
I have a hard time
believing this,
but you were like the slowest
on the team originally?
- I couldn't even, I mean,
I was like really fit
for being a defender,
center defender in soccer.
You are sprint
fast, you're middy,
no one's gonna knock you over,
but you can't run four miles.
- It's a totally
different body type.
- It's totally different.
I was like, you know, dense.
I was really, really dense.
And I think that that agility
and that athleticism carried
me and kept me healthy
not a single injury until after
the Olympics, pretty solid,
but it did mean that
when I got to Dartmouth,
I was really a
fish out of water,
like across the country
first winter of my life
and could not run more than
four miles without walking
and it was humiliating
to be very honest.
And I was failing classes
'cause I was not super prepared
for the academics there.
I definitely called
my dad and I was like,
this was all a mistake.
- Wow, what did he say?
- He said, "just
keep trying Lex."
'Cause that's all he ever says.
And I knew he wasn't gonna
be the type of parent,
he's not a dragon parent,
but he wasn't gonna give me
the option to quit anything.
And I knew, and I
wrote this in the book
that the good thing
and the bad thing
about not giving up
is that it works,
and I knew that it was
gonna be a long climb up.
I just wanted to
score a team point
but then I couldn't do it.
Like no matter what
anyone else thought of me
when I was really, really slow,
I knew that with time and
patience, I could do it.
It just was gonna be
really uncomfortable.
- Well, you had said
that you had this feeling
that there was a
champion inside of you.
Like that's something
that you carried with you
like this idea that there was
greatness packed inside of you
even if it wasn't being manifest
in that moment like
where does that
come from?
- Where does it come from?
Well, I think that
comes from my mom too,
because when you feel,
and I don't know how
healthy this is to say,
but when you feel so like...
It was so wild what I saw
and experienced as a child,
like some of the memories
of her were so unbelievable
that I truly felt that if the
most unbelievably bad things
were true then the most
unbelievably good things
could be true, which I
think is a survival thing.
And also that I was special.
I was special because
this awful thing happened
and then I would be
capable of the opposite.
Like it was almost
like, if this is true,
then the opposite
must be true too.
So there's always something
inside of me that was like,
that believed, suspended
disbelief or believed
that I was, I don't know,
like part mythical or
something, you know,
something like really-
- Did that extended
to being an Olympian?
Like when you're the slowest
on the team at Dartmouth
are you thinking, I'm
gonna go to the Olympics?
- So, no, and that's another
really interesting thing
that I think is important
for people to understand
is that I never planned
more than a year of
my life in advance.
And that's so important to share
because had I planned
five years in the future,
I would have counted
myself short.
I would have put a limit
on what I was capable of
'cause I definitely
didn't even think about
being capable of
going to the Olympics
when I was a
freshman in college,
but I also didn't
think past a year.
So I wasn't like,
it's not possible.
I just didn't think about it.
And this is still
how I live my life
where I'm like the next year,
these are the goals, this is,
like, I have big dreams,
but they're more
how I wanna feel
not like what I'm
gonna accomplish.
And I think that's an important
thing to share with people
because probably most of us
might sell ourselves short
if we were to ask ourselves,
where will I be in
five or 10 years?
I don't know, maybe that's
not true, but for me it was.
- Well, I think that we
all wildly overestimate
what we can do in a year
and wildly underestimate what
can be done in many years,
five years, 10 years, right?
- Have said that before?
- I have said this before.
- And is that how
you live your life?
- I mean, I set goals
for myself, but I
don't dwell on them.
I'm really focused on what
the next thing to do is,
I try to stay more present,
which is sort of a variation,
I think on what you're saying.
And I've learned to trust my
intuition and my instinct.
So I hold those goals,
like they're out there,
but I hold them loosely and
I'm always making adjustments.
- And how important to you,
and like, I'm so
genuinely curious,
is it that other
people believe in you?
Like did it matter more
when you were certain time
in your life or did it ever
matter, does it matter now?
- I mean, you know, I'm an
unapologetic people pleaser
and premised huge parts of my
life on external validation.
So I'm very connected to that
aspect of what
drives achievement.
But some of the course
corrections that I've made later
in life were really motivated
by trying to figure out
what drives me as opposed
to trying to do the thing
that's gonna get
me the accolades
or the approval of
people that I care about.
And that's still a struggle
and a growth thing, you know?
- Yeah, it reminds me of...
I went to this class day speech
the year before I graduated
at Dartmouth and it was like,
here's five pieces of advice.
And one of them was like,
your time in the frat basement
is not a waste of time,
like some of those things
that are just like
the gray, you know-
- I spent a little bit of time
in the frat basements
at Dartmouth.
- You know, that's
how I met Jeremy.
That's how I met
the love of my life.
- With the journals along
the wall down there?
- Just the worst, right?
- It's unbelievable.
- It's where it's an....
But one of the things
he said was that
as long as you're not doing
something actively bad
in the world like working for
a company that hurts people,
you know, as long as
you're not doing bad,
you're probably doing good.
And what he was addressing, I
think was that so many of us
in college were like, we
should work for a nonprofit,
we should go into
the Peace Corps.
Like there were certain
pillars that meant
you were doing
good in the world.
But what he was trying to say
was that as long as
you are not doing bad,
as long as you're manifesting
the greatest version
of yourself, you're probably
doing good in the world.
And that was really
helpful to hear
because I was about to
go chase an Olympic dream
which felt very
selfish, exactly.
And even some of this
creative stuff, I mean,
it's a team effort, but
I'm pursuing the arts.
And I think to hear
that meant a lot to me,
'cause it meant that simply
following my North stars
would do good in the world
even if it's not the same idea
of good-
- Right.
Like flipping the lens such
that you're not looking at it
as indulgent but actually
like the world needs everybody
to be the best version
of who they are.
Like we need a little bit more
of that messaging
out there, I think.
- Yeah, and that was important
'cause it can feel a little,
I think some dream
chasers can feel selfish.
And I think it's only selfish
if it's not your real dream
or if you're not committed.
It's only not great if you
don't commit all the way.
- So you end up committing
all the way kind of, right?
'Cause you're
doing other things,
but I'm interested in that like,
was there an inflection point
in your running at Dartmouth
where it all
started to click in?
Like you go from
being the slowest,
I mean, by the time
you graduate, you're
killing it, right?
So, you're
progressing as you go.
Was there a moment where
it all connected for you
or was it just a gradual growth?
- It was gradual.
It appears more sudden
because junior year I
started scoring team points.
It kind of seems like it was
sudden when I was a senior
but the truth is that the
reality is that it's gradual.
And I think that's
how all dreams are.
They happen very, very
slowly and then all at once,
and most people only see
the all at once moment.
It was, you know, I
added practically,
I mean this is what
actually happened.
I added 10 miles a week
to my mileage every year
for four or five years, it
was just 10 miles a week.
So I was like 30 miles a
week, 40 as a sophomore,
50 as a junior, 60 as a
senior, 70 miles a week-
- These are tiny
adjustments really.
- Just tiny and I
stayed healthy, right?
And then shifts that
I always tried to see
as choices not sacrifices,
I drank a lot of
beer my freshman year
and I stopped drinking a lot
of beer my junior year, right?
So certain choices that I made
that were helping
my performance,
but I probably wasn't
mature enough as a freshmen
not to explore those things.
Like that was what I
felt I needed to do.
And it did help.
I just think
information is helpful.
Like I remember someone
came and talked to us
and he was like a heavy
night of drinking,
he was like a pro athlete,
sets you back two
weeks in training.
And that simple equation
made it a lot easier
for me to make those
decisions to be honest,
'cause it wasn't this
abstract, like drinking's bad.
I was like, how bad is it?
And he's like, two weeks
bad. And I'm like, okay.
So if I value my time
and I don't wanna go back
two weeks in training,
I won't drink that much.
You know, it doesn't
mean never drink.
There's a time and a place
where you wouldn't care
about the last two
weeks of training
like at the end of the season.
Does that make sense?
So it was like little
decisions that then added up.
I think having Mark
Coogan become my coach.
He also gave me permission
to believe in myself
and it came from
the right place.
It was different for my dad
to say, "Lex you can it,"
than to hear it
from an Olympian.
That's powerful and I think
that's back to the question
I asked you of how much
does it matter to you
that people you revere
and admire tell you,
I give you permission
to chase this-
- well, it's everything.
It's everything and
that idea of mentorship
or having those kinds of
heroes is like a recurring
huge theme in your book.
- Yeah, but you seek them
out like a fisherman.
Like I feel that some
people think these mentors
are just gonna come to you.
And sometimes they do
in the form of a coach
that you happen upon
but oftentimes we have to grab
the mentor and allow them in.
- And it is true like
when that one person
that you have so
much respect for
just says something that
maybe a week from then
they forget about but makes all
the difference in your life.
- Yes, and that also goes
to what I say in the world
because now people
have their eyes on me.
So I need to-
- All those braveries
running around
with buns on top of their head.
- I love, aaw.
Some buns maybe, you know,
some of them are boys and
maybe they don't have a button,
maybe they do, but yeah.
- It's the most adorable
tribe of fans out there.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, it's really cool.
And how you communicate with
them with verse and poetry
and the inspiration that you
share I think is really cool
and so uniquely you.
- Thank you.
I'm trying to give them
something to imitate
or to latch onto that I feel
comfortable with them imitating
or would have hoped that
I could have latched onto
when I was there in their shoes
because I don't think
it's that useful to say,
I just ran 120 miles a
week at this minute average
'cause that's not that
useful to a 15-year old girl.
Like they don't need
to run that many miles.
But they can put
their hair up like me
or they can go on a long run,
whatever that means to them.
- Or they can dare
to have a big dream.
- They can dare to
have a big dream.
And I'm someone who will take
your dreams very seriously.
So like with my friends,
I don't think I'm the person
to call and like cry to
because usually I just
will try to navigate
and figure out what the next-
- Solution.
- Yeah, and yeah.
- So tell the story of how
the bravey thing started?
- Yeah, so bravey started
when I wrote a poem
on social media, which
was run like a bravery,
sleep like a baby,
dream like a crazy,
replace can't with maybe.
And bravery was this word,
came from the word brave,
but not a real word,
and I think it stuck
because so many of the words
that I chased
growing up felt very,
they felt very outward facing.
So, like strong, pretty, fierce,
those felt like words that
I presented to the world
and bravey because
it's not a real word,
because it comes from the word
brave felt more like a choice
like an inward facing word
that you assigned to yourself
and that you decide exactly
what that means to you
and I liked that.
I liked giving the
world something,
giving myself something
that I could simply
choose to be.
- And it's also not telling
you that you need to be brave.
You just need to be bravey.
Like you kind of just to be
in the orbit of brave, right?
It's very inviting
and nonthreating.
- Yes, I think so, too, right.
'Cause you're just making
choices to chase your dreams
and it has a lightness
to it I think.
And hopefully it's playful
because dream chasing,
dream chasing is hard
enough that I think
finding some lightness is good.
- Right, right.
And it becomes like a thing.
This brave thing explodes,
becomes the name of your tribe.
It becomes the
name of your book.
- Yeah, well, that I give
my editors credit for it
'cause I was like we can't
call the book "Bravey".
No one knows what this is
and they're like, they will.
- That's more reason to do it.
- They're like, they will.
- Like "Bravey" what is this?
- What is it?
- Tell me more.
- Yeah, I'm grateful to
put something in the world
that I feel is
adding to the world.
You know, I think
it's a good tool.
And I think it's a good
lesson to tell yourself
that you can just decide
that you're something
and that it makes
it more inevitable.
Like when Jeremy and I
have a goal or a dream,
we usually talk about it as
if it's real before it's real.
Whether it's, we
named our pug Bernini
before she even existed,
we were just like,
when we get Bernini,
Bernini, Bernini,
and then we get a pug,
but I think it's the same
with any dream we're chasing,
where like, talk about it
as if it's real and
put a label on it.
And then the world and you will-
- Right, everything tends
to then coalesce around it.
I think that's really powerful.
I mean, anybody who's made
an independent feature
will tell you the same.
Like you just start making it,
like you just assume
the money's gonna happen
and all these element,
like all the variables,
the eight billion variables
will somehow come together.
But it starts with that belief
and then the action
on the belief.
Like just start moving forward
as if it's all sorted out.
- Yes, and you know, that's
the very opposite mindset of...
I was just thinking about
like when I was sick,
I thought I knew the future
in a way that was
really unhealthy.
'Cause I was like the
future, it will be bad.
This will never get better.
And I feel like the minute
we think we know exactly
what's gonna happen, it's
a little bit of a shift
of what you're just saying,
but that's actually a red flag.
Like when you're like,
this will never get better.
I think like a healthy mind
is one that's like, you know,
these are inevitable goals,
but I don't really know
how it's gonna happen
or what, you know-
- Right.
But not letting the
unknowing prevent you from-
- From chasing, yeah.
- Yeah, from chasing it, yeah.
So, on the bravery poem thing,
this is not like a one-off
like you're a poet,
like you study
poetry at Dartmouth-
- I graduated at the top of
my creative writing class
and that took a lot of writing.
- Yeah, I would imagine
it's reflected in your book.
I mean, one of the things
that I love about the way
that you wrote this book,
you know, most athlete
memoirs are terrible.
And it's generally
because, in my opinion,
because they're
written by an athlete
typically with a ghost writer
near or at the end
of their career.
And they're used as
like marketing tools
to extend the longevity
of that career
or to try to create
interest in this person
for sponsorship
reasons or whatnot.
And they're like overly heroic
and they just feel
not dishonest,
but not terribly honest either.
And it's the rare
person who can execute
on an athlete memoir with
a level of vulnerability
and like emotional awareness
that you have done here.
And with all these writing
chops that you have,
it just makes for a
very potent combination.
And I love the way
that it's very lyrical
in the way that it's
written in that, you know,
there's a linear story
but it's not really
about the linear story.
Like you've extracted
out the most emotional
important moments and described
those kind of, you know,
it's more like a string
of pearls than it is like,
this happened, then this
happened, then this happened,
and just the honesty
and the humor
and the level of self-awareness
I think is really beautiful.
- Thank you. That's
that means a lot.
And I know you know your stuff.
- I'm like well, as somebody
who's written a book like this,
like I was embarrassed for
myself reading this book
'cause I was like, this book
is so much better than my book.
I was like, I should
have done it like that.
Like, why did I do this?
Anyway, it's quite
an accomplishment.
- I really, really
appreciate that
and it's definitely the
proudest thing I've ever done.
I feel like, man, it's fun
when you've done something
and it's about to be
released in the world
and you know that
you did your best.
I really liked that feeling.
- It's really exciting
and it's very exciting
and it's like a real thing
that exists in the world.
- Yeah, it's a tangible thing.
And it's, and we're
in, I'm not...
It's funny when you're
like, your editors are like,
there's no more changes and
you're like, okay, I accept it
that this is it.
And Tara Schuster
was one of the blurbs
and she said that it
felt like a kind knife.
And I thought that was like
a really big compliment
because I think what people
are expecting in this book
is like more poems and
encouraging somethings
and those are in there,
but those somethings came
from something really dark
and really challenging.
And I think that what she said
and what you said are really,
really mean a lot to me because
it means that I communicated
and it's one thing
to have an experience
because I didn't need to
write this book honestly
for myself, I have
had these experiences.
I'm very happy with where I am.
But I really wanted
to work hard enough
and find a way to
communicate them.
And that's a whole other world.
It's just putting it in
a way where it translates
and it speaks to people who
don't know you possibly.
- Right, and you don't...
It is an athlete memoir but
it's really not about that.
It's just about life, you know?
And you don't shy away
from the darkness.
I mean, there's some really
difficult stuff in there.
You know, one of your
memories of your mom
it was really painful to read.
- It was painful-
- Yeah, I can't imagine.
I can't imagine.
- It was so crazy.
Some of that stuff it's like,
I don't know if you can relate,
but when you're
writing a memoir,
you're like, wow,
is my life worth?
Is it like, you know,
it means that you thought-
- We'll talk about indulgence,
you're like, really?
- Yeah, you're like...
(both laughing)
It's like you thought you
were worthy of writing this.
Like that takes a
certain gusto I think
just like chasing a
dream and you're like,
I think I can do this,
but yeah, I just...
I think I've like been to
the peaks of of some worlds
and to the bottoms
of some worlds
and that means that hopefully
I can reach the people
in between and that's
a unique role to be in
because I know how much it
meant when certain people
said certain things to me,
it went 100 times further than
if somebody else had said it.
And we've said this in
this conversation before
but I recognize I was in a
position to say something
and that the more detail I
could go into at this book,
like the more specific I would
be, the more it would reach.
Isn't that the rule
of storytelling?
The more specific we can get
and the more personal?
- The most specific
but also the more honest and
the more vulnerable, right?
Because that's where
people can really find
the emotional connection.
- Yeah, well, you know what's
funny about this last week
with the New York
Times thing is,
I feel like I'm at a
turning point right now
where the truth is that I've
worked really hard to make sure
that my film, my acting,
stands on its own pillar
and my running stands
on its own pillar,
and I actually finally feel
that I've let those worlds talk
to each other in this book
in a way that might allow me,
and I feel it, to just
be exactly who I am
a little bit more comfortably,
and I think that all
comes from within, right?
Like I'm in the Hollywood
world, but I still feel like,
oh, I didn't come up like
all these actors did.
I was spending a lot of time
performing on a circular track
or oval track.
And I think before I
might've seen myself
as needing to hide one world
when I was in the other,
and now I actually feel like
it's okay that I have come,
that I am exactly who I am.
And I wish I had
felt that way sooner,
but I think it's okay
that I feel that way now.
- It's interesting
that you say that
because your movies
are so reflective
of your emotional
experience as an athlete.
They do stand on their own,
but they're also inextricably
linked to each other.
- But that was a smart
decision as a filmmaker
to tell a story in
a world that I'm in
and know and have access to.
Like that was a
business woman knowing,
I mean, a creative person
knowing that the best story
I can tell is my own
or the world I'm in.
And I think all
filmmakers do that
even if it's an
emotional reality
they know not an
actual reality, right?
So, I think that was still
my filmmaking cap on it.
It wasn't me saying, I really
wish these worlds were one.
It was just, what's the
best movie I can make,
and that was the best
movie I could make.
- Right, because it's inspired
by your own experiences
and it's something that
you know very well.
And it's interesting
in looking at the book
like things that
actually happened to you
are then translated into
some narrative that shows up
in one of your movies through
one of the characters.
- Yeah, I think a lot of
filmmakers are like that, right?
A lot of like a
writer directors.
- I'm sure. I'm sure.
- Yeah, yeah.
So I'm just doing what they do.
I'm doing what they do-
- Looking your book,
I'm like looking at the
people that blurbed your book
and it's like, it's just this
weird Venn diagram of worlds.
It's like Shalane Flanagan,
and then like, wait, Jay
Duplass like Mindy Kaling,
like what is going on here?
It's wild that you have
your feet planted so firmly
in these two different worlds
and how they intersect
in this book.
- And those people have been,
I mean, Jay as an example,
you know that I met
him on a run here.
Like I met him randomly.
So he's a runner and-
- See, I just figured
you guys are in some cool
Hollywood group where
you all sit around
and share each other's
screenplays or something.
- Yeah, no, no.
- I'm sure.
- But the truth is that I
met him while I was running
and it was pouring rain
and he was running,
we were both on long
runs and I recognized him
and I just listened to his book.
And I was running with a girl
who had no idea who he was.
And I was like, we have to stop,
I'm sorry, like I have to.
You know those moments
where you're like,
this will never happen again.
And he knew who I was
because he knew Nick Kroll
and he had seen
"Olympic Dreams",
and I don't feel like this is
something that I try to make
the most of opportunities.
And in that instance, I was
like, can I send you a link
to our movie or whatever.
And we eventually got lunch
and he's a mentor now.
But that was, he's
someone who...
There are a few people who
I think like understand
both worlds and who are
helping me see myself
in their world, and
that means a lot to me.
- That's cool. That's very cool.
- But the point of that I
think is just that like,
I'm very grateful to that,
to the people who
do that for me.
- Well, you're your
awareness of that,
your consciousness
of that is reflected
in how you communicate
to your audience.
Like, I can tell that
you're very mindful
of making sure that you're
fulfilling that role
for the people that are
out there looking for you
to give them a lead.
- Hopefully I hope it,
I hope the book also gives
a more realistic view
of how it happens.
Because if you see someone
just where they are
in any one moment today,
you probably would assume
any number of paths
got them there
that aren't the real
way that got them there.
- And when you're an
Olympian, that's on steroids.
- Whatever it is-
- We just think that Olympians
they just come out of the womb
fully baked as the superhero.
- Yeah, and it's usually more
circuitous or unexpected.
But what message does
that send to kids?
And is it like don't
chase the Olympic dream
or just like chase
the Olympic dream
but make sure you're also
manifesting your full self.
What are we telling them?
- Well, I don't know, you tell
me what you're telling them.
You're the one who's
doing the telling.
I mean, I would say that
if I had to translate
what you're trying
to put out there,
it's saying, it's okay
to have a big dream.
It's okay to feel different,
understand that it's hard
anything worth doing
or doing really well
is gonna be difficult, but
embrace those challenges,
like be brave, like in
everything that you do,
bravery is the recurring mantra.
I don't know how many times
it's said in your movies
and it's the title of your
book, like this is the thing.
And bravery is to, you
know, exercise courage
in the face of fear.
It's not about being afraid,
it's about having the
willingness to, you know,
deal with the fear, right?
- Try your best.
Yeah, yeah. I think it's
about trying your best.
So maybe that's also it that
as long as you're
trying your best,
it won't go as you
thought it would,
but you keep trying your best.
And it is brave to try your best
because trying your
best means if you fail,
you'll know that you
did try your best
whereas sandbagging is
like where you purposefully
don't try your
best so that later,
you can tell yourself
that narrative.
So perhaps the bravest thing
of all is to try your best
because then whatever
happens to you,
you know was like
your honest effort.
- Right, and to try your best
requires you to be vulnerable.
Like when you're sandbagging,
you're hiding, right?
You're indulging that fear
and you're giving
yourself an out
and it's scary to say, I'm
gonna remove all the excuses
and put it all out there and
whatever happens happens.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, I had a question
that just came up
that I wanted to ask
you, can I ask you?
- You can, but this is
a podcast about you.
- I know but it doesn't matter.
It's always gonna come back.
You're very good at making
it all the way to come back.
Do you like, because I was
thinking about manifesting
your greatest self and one of
the things is like the people
you spend time around.
'Cause it just occurred
to me that with your life,
you've structured in a way
where you spend time with people
in this context that
maybe you admire
or that you'd like
to spend time with.
Do you feel like you...
Well, do you purposefully
put yourself in situations
to be around people like that?
And do you also take an
effort to not be around people
who don't do that for you?
Whatever that is.
- Well, to the former point
100% or what do you think?
This whole podcast is basically
a grand scheme to be able
to hoodwink cool people
like yourself to spend time,
like I hold them hostage here
and force them to answer
all these questions.
And then I incorporate
them into my life.
It's very indulgent and
self-serving in that regard.
I seek out people
that inspire me
and I've given them a compelling
reason to come and meet me
by amplifying and sharing
what they have to say
and quite often like
these people then become
people in my life.
Like in the way
that you met Jay,
like a lot of guests that
I've had are my friends now.
And that's the most
incredible gift
because these are people
I can call on for advice
or who have made
themselves available to me.
And I don't take that lightly.
I don't take it
for granted at all.
Like it's a huge, huge gift.
And it's just been the
most expansive experience
that I could've ever
structured for myself.
To the point about avoiding,
you know, it's the adage is.
You're the average of like
the however many people
you spend the most
time with, right?
So choose wisely,
like spend your time
with high vibrating people
that are demonstrating
characteristics that
you aspire to manifest
in your own life.
Of course that means
spending less time
with people who are
dragging you down.
That's a little bit
more difficult for me,
but I feel like I've done a
pretty good job of over time
setting healthier boundaries
around that kind of thing.
- That's cool, yeah.
- What about you?
- Yes, I think that I'm doing
a better job of that as well
but also recognizing that
I think separating the work
from quality time in my life,
and that includes, when Jeremy
and I, we work together,
so separating our work time
from our quality time together
but also understanding
in my own life
like there are
circumstances where we must,
we have colleagues,
we have interactions
and hopefully those
are people we love,
but there's sometimes
there's work, right?
- Yeah.
- But, but making sure
that I preserve the time
that I need to like reinflate
or fill myself back up because
that will be important.
- How does the athlete
mindset contribute
to your creative pursuits?
Like most people who
are kind of involved
in that world, don't come
from an athlete background
and certainly not as robust
an athlete background
as you have.
Do you feel like there
are tools and tactics
that you've learned as a
runner that benefit you
when it comes to breaking
a story for a script
or executing on what
needs to be done
to get this movie
up on its feet?
- For sure, there's like...
So let's just take the idea
of like writer's block, okay?
So like people have
created this idea
that there is such thing.
And I think that would be
like showing up to a workout,
and I know you don't always
feel great every day,
but it would be like being
like, I just can't even try.
Like I can't even take a
step and it's like, okay,
it might not go the way
you think it's gonna go
but you can warm up and
you can do certain things
that will lead you,
point you towards, sorry,
you can do certain things
that will point
you toward success.
And as athletes we
put on our outfit
that will set us up for success.
Maybe we lay out our
clothes the night before,
we eat the food we know is
gonna set us up for success.
We go to the trail
that we know we love
or go to the track,
we meet people.
So there are things that
we put in place to show up
and give ourselves the best
chance to try our best.
And I think with the
creative world, it's similar,
like wear the outfit that makes
you feel like you can rise.
Sit at the desk that you like,
use the pen that you like
or computer, you know,
get the right lighting,
like set it up for yourself.
And I think that has been one
thing that I do a good job of
is like curating the
environment to try my best.
- To make it
conducive to success.
But at the same time, the
big difference in my mind
is that as an athlete,
it's much more binary,
especially as an
endurance athlete.
Okay, if I put in the
a hundred mile weeks
and I do these things,
like you're setting yourself
up for the best result.
Like, you know, it's
mathematical in some regards
but creativity is
elusive and mysterious
and it doesn't always
come when you summon it.
- Yes, but I think that then,
I think we can point
to the rule of thirds,
which I was told by a coach.
This is in the book
but I think it's life-changing-
- I love the rule of thirds.
- It's amazing.
So my Olympic coach told me
after a particularly
challenging workout
where I could not hit my splits
before going to the Rio
Olympics, that that was okay,
it was the rule of thirds.
And he was an Olympian,
so I always soaked
in everything he said
and I was like, what's
the rule of thirds?
And he said, "when
you're chasing a dream
or doing anything hard,
you're meant to feel
good a third of the time,
okay a third of the time, and
crappy a third of the time.
And if the ratio is
roughly in that range,
then you're doing fine.
So today was the crappy day
along your dream chasing."
And if the ratio is off like
you feel too good all the time
or too bad, then you got to
look at if you're fatiguing
or not trying hard enough
or pushing yourself.
So I think with those days
that you're talking about
where like creativity doesn't
come or it doesn't feel great,
you still show up because
maybe that's your crappy day.
But it doesn't mean
that you quit the goal.
It doesn't mean you freak out.
It means that you show up
and live through that crappy
or that dip because
you're chasing a dream
and you're doing something hard.
So I think I've been able
to embrace the ups and downs
of the creative dream chasing
by way of understanding
the parallel in
the athletic world.
And likewise in
running, I rarely win.
Like I've won races,
but to not win a race
doesn't mean that I
haven't done really well.
And there's a lot of
nos you get in Hollywood
like when you're
trying to make a movie.
And I think just being
able to weather the nos
like weather all of that
and take it not as a loss.
And to take criticism
like blood work.
I think that's another thing
that was an epiphany.
- Oh, tell me about that.
I like this.
- Okay, so blood work, right?
If you don't get
your blood tested,
it doesn't mean
that you don't have
low iron or high cholesterol,
it just means you haven't
found out about it, right?
- Right.
- It's fact, it's blood work.
And I think similarly with
like creative criticism
or feedback we might get
on a script or whatever,
if I don't ask for the feedback,
it doesn't mean that
I did a good job.
It just means that
I'm refusing to know
what I could've done better.
And looking at it
like blood work
has felt a lot less
emotional and offensive,
it's just like, this
is just feedback.
It's just my blood work.
And I want to have it
so that I can improve.
And that helped me a
lot to flip that switch.
- Right, like resiliency
plus the hustle
and the dedication of
getting up and showing up
on days when you
don't feel like it
are things you
learn as an athlete
that of course are life lessons.
I'm reminded of an anecdote
that I recently heard.
Timothy Olyphant tell,
he was on my friend
John Moffitt's Podcast.
And a lot of people
don't know this,
but like Timothy Olyphant
was an amazing swimmer.
Like at USC, he was very good.
He didn't make the Olympics
but he was a very
outstanding athlete.
And when he decided he
wanted to be an actor
and came into the awareness
that like it's one in 100,000
or 10,000 that make it,
you know the odds are
stacked against you,
while he was waiting tables,
he would ask these other people
who are trying to be actors
like, well, what are you doing?
And they'd be like, well,
I'm going to auditions
or my uncle knows a guy
who might know a guy
who's gonna set me up here.
Meanwhile, Timothy
is like taking class.
Like he approached
it like an athlete.
Like what are the steps
that I need to take
to put myself in the best
position for success?
And he's like, when he
would hear those stories,
he's like, well,
that's one less person
I have to worry about
competing against.
And it's interesting
how, my point being that
there is something to be
said for the athlete mindset
approach to creative pursuits.
When we look at
creative pursuits
is like these unpredictable
realms in which
not always the
best people succeed
and some people who are
less deserving are rewarded.
Like it's very much
not a meritocracy
but there are things that
you could do to put yourself
in a position to succeed
when that moment arises.
- Yes, and to build a
stronger foundation, right?
'Cause the people for whom
they have random connections
or this and that, it's easy
to feel jealous of people
who you perceive to be
having a shortcut or two,
but if you can always lean
back on a strong backbone
of whatever that means,
whether it's his preparations
of his classes or
whatever that means to you
like that backbone,
it'll be there.
But I do think that every
artist has to face a moment
probably every athlete too,
where you ask yourself,
are you interested in this
goal or are you committed?
And that's a big
difference, right?
Where if you are merely
interested in a goal,
you're going to find the
reasons why it wasn't possible
for you or you're gonna
back out when it hurts
or when you get one no.
And if you're committed, then
you will keep showing up.
So that's how I feel about that.
- How does it work
working with Jeremy?
- It's great, so I think
Jeremy and I, similar to you
are thriving when we're
doing these things
we're so passionate about.
So we're not misaligned in that.
We're very much aligned
that we enjoy our work
and we enjoy working together.
It's a different
way to love someone
when you have a common goal,
because it makes us both
family and teammates,
which are different, right?
Like family, you love no
matter what and it's family.
Friends, I think you choose
and that's a different
kind of relationship.
You don't rely on
them for anything,
and teammates, you have a goal.
It's very, very fun and it's
a really enriching experience
to share a goal with someone.
It's hard to because you
kind of need them to show up
and you're leaning on
them as a teammate.
We have different strengths.
So we've learned more
about like what each of us
brings to the table.
And I would not be where I am
even as an athlete without him,
'cause it's so much a blurred
line of getting it done,
whatever it takes,
whatever it means.
- But there's no way
in making a movie
that you're not
gonna have conflicts
over what you think is the
right way to do something.
So how do you navigate that
and keep your
relationship intact?
- Yeah, that's a good question.
I mean, we, you know,
I think you'd go back
to the rule of thirds.
Like being in love is
also a dream of sorts.
And so it doesn't
always feel good.
Like it does feel crappy
a third of the time,
but that's because I'm
not married to myself.
So, it's not always
gonna be, you know,
and when we are
working on something,
I think we instinctually know
when to like give or take,
like we respect
each other enough
to respect the
other person's idea
even if it wasn't our own.
And we have tried
to put into place
vocabulary that allows
us to move forward
during conflict more gracefully.
So for example, we will
use this word, recalibrate,
which basically just means
if something needs to shift,
like I need to try to respond
to his ideas in this way,
even though my instinct,
my whole life has been to
respond in this other way,
if I can have the maturity
to just recalibrate
and never go back
to that old way,
and he can allow me to be a
mature person who can grow,
that's a kind thing
for him and for me.
So we use this word recalibrate
when we need to like grow
and grow instantly.
And I think this hearkens back
to that word bravery of like,
you can choose to be
a bravery right now
and then your bravery for
the rest of your life.
And I think with recalibrating,
that can be anything from,
I'm no longer a person
who apologizes every two
seconds, which I used to be.
I'm just not that anymore.
So I think that has helped
us to grow when we need to
to level up and-
- You have a crazy amount
of emotional maturity.
How old are you?
- I'm 30.
On my 30th.
- I can't...
I mean, don't even get me
started on what I was doing
when I was 30, but like
that is impressive.
- Well, it's not, and
it's not always a...
That takes a lot
of, we don't always,
we are normal people
who fight, right?
But we really love each
other more than any of these.
Oh, you know what? I think is
also just that this whole film
world and the running world,
they're sandboxes and we're
playing in them, right?
Like I went through this
depression with Jeremy
and that was the
worst thing, right?
So I think also we have
the overall stability
and safety to know
that we're playing.
That's always
important too, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well you just, I mean, you
haven't lived in Los Angeles
that long, right?
So when you were
making these movies,
you weren't even living here.
So you were kind of outside
of the sort of downside
or the toxic aspects of,
quote unquote, Hollywood.
- Yes, and even now we live in
the Valley just like you do.
(both laughing) And I
think that's a little bit-
- But not so out of it
that you're not gonna run
into Jay Duplass
when you go running.
But that, the feeling that that
could happen that's amazing.
- Well, that's a crazy
thing about living in LA
or in New York too,
but like, you know,
you could just run into anybody.
- You can.
- And these people
that you look up to
who are doing the thing
that you aspire to do
are like around at
the grocery store.
- Yes, and before that,
I felt like I needed to
create these interactions
and that's why
podcasts are important.
Because when I lived in
these mountain towns,
I craved those, like,
those interactions.
I craved like the spontaneity,
I craved mentorship basically
and I was living in a tiny town.
And so I think I
created those moments
by listening to podcasts.
And I still love
podcasts and audio books
but it has a different
role in my life
than it did when I never thought
there would be a possibility
to run into someone
which was mostly the case when
I was in Eugene, for example.
- Right, well, the mentors
are just different there.
You're gonna run into running
mentors and athletic mentors.
- That's true. That's very true.
But, yeah, I don't know.
- We have to talk
about "Olympic Dreams".
Can we talk about this?
- we can talk about it.
- I look at "Tracktown"
and as insane as that was
to compete in the Olympics
and make a feature film
in the same year,
it's like all right,
well, how can we up the
degree of difficulty?
I know we're gonna make a
movie, a narrative feature film
in the middle of the Olympic
games in the Olympic village.
- It was so fun.
- So crazy.
- It was so fun, so-
- It looked fun. It looked hard.
I mean, it didn't
come off looking hard
but as I'm watching
it, I'm like,
how the fuck did they do this?
This is unbelievable.
- Well, we made friends with
the team USA chiropractor
for their bobsled
team because Jeremy,
so we had a one-man band.
It was Jeremy,
Nick Kroll, and I,
and Jeremy was the
cinematographer,
the director, and the sound guy,
because these permissions
to go into the village
are so difficult and rare.
So Jeremy was in the
most pain, I would say,
by carrying all the equipment.
But it was really felt
like the feeling you'd
wanna have on any set,
which is intimate,
like friends trying
to pull something off,
like it was a pure adventure.
And I felt so happy there.
I felt so happy.
And I was healing
actually a broken SI
and I was in pain, but I was
more happy than I was in pain.
I remember that.
I remember that it was a little
painful, but I was so joyful
that it like overtook that.
- It's like this perfect
melding of the two worlds
that you care most about,
like coming together
for this special experience.
I mean, we should say, the
movie is about an Olympian
that you play and her experience
of competing at the Olympics
and dealing with the
emotions of the aftermath
and this encounter that she has
with a dentist
played by Nick Kroll,
inspired by this real dentist
that you had become friendly
with when you were in Rio
and what ensues with
their relationship
and how their pain meets
and how they both kind of
come away from that experience
a little bit more complete.
And to me it felt there's
definitely overtones
of lost in translation
in the movie.
Like there's a similar
sensibility to it,
but there's also a
little light dusting
of curb your enthusiasm
at moments with Nick,
you know like when he's
interacting with these athletes,
like that is hilarious.
- And it was cool
because these athletes,
so these were all real athletes
competing in that Olympics.
And I would find them
in the dining hall
or in the game room.
And if they didn't
look super stressed
like they weren't about to
compete, if they looked relaxed,
I would ask if they
wanted to come to a scene
for this movie, we were
making with Nick Kroll,
and what was cool is that
athletes were very used
to being on camera
and being interviewed,
but that's a certain
posture that we have
and there's certain
ways that we talk.
And because of the
small crew that we had
and because Nick is
so good with people,
he was able to draw out, I
think a real human side of them
and a different side than the
typical coverage might offer.
They were just being themselves.
- And it's all pretty
much improv, right?
Like when you see these
athletes in the dentist chair
and Nick Kroll, he starts
talking about his ex fiance
and how he's having a hard time.
And the look on the
faces of the athletes.
They're like, what am I
supposed to do with this?
- It was so great.
And that was partly because
Nick knew his character
really, really well.
And that's like, when
we do improv in movies,
the most important thing
is that we know who we are,
so that if we're
in any scenario,
we know what our
characters would do.
So that was, you know, speaking
back to how do you compare
the athletics to the arts?
Just preparation, right?
We were prepared so that
whatever that circus
of an environment
brought, we could do it.
- And you have a
ticking clock, right?
Like this has to be completed
by the time the games
are done because you're
not gonna be able
to recreate that environment.
- For sure, and you don't
wanna get in anyone's way.
Like the last thing you wanna
do is like alter someone's
Olympic experience, the
real Olympic experience.
So we were really
careful about that.
- But you're in, I mean,
just so people understand,
like you're in the
Olympic dining hall
and it's filled with
athletes who are eating
and you're just
navigating around them.
So there's this documentary
kind of vibe to the whole thing.
- Yeah, yeah, and it
was such a privilege
because the best part
about the Olympics
to me as an athlete was
the village experience.
Like the village is pure magic.
It is everybody with their
guard down, 24-hour dining hall,
everyone's in these costumes,
I mean, their uniforms.
You have to wear your
country's uniform.
It's like a Wes Anderson
movie, but real, real life.
And to be able to like give
people a peek into that world
and do it in a way that
wasn't documentary,
that like had a
narrative through line
that could have happened
was such a like thrill
and such a joy and the
thing I was most nervous for
same with "Tracktown",
was when my Olympic
peers saw the movie.
So Gus Kenworthy was
at the premier and-
- He was in the movie.
- And was in the movie,
but I was really nervous
for what he would think,
just like I was nervous
for what my running peers
would think of "Tracktown"
because even though I want
this movie to speak to a
broader cinematic audience,
I want it to speak to the world
that I'm representing first
to make sure, you know, I
want it to be authentic.
And it was such a...
I felt really grateful that
people who are Olympians
were like, yeah, I would
show my kids that one day
just to show them what it was
like to be at the Olympics.
You know, it felt it
was what it was like.
- Yeah, there's an
emotional honesty to it.
I mean, you see, you get
glimpses of the high highs
and what we, as average people
would project that experience
might be about, but
you shine a spot.
It's really about those
moments in between.
Like, what does it feel
like after you're done
and you're just wandering
around the village
trying to figure out
what's gonna come next?
Or sitting alone
in the cafeteria
or going back to your dorm room,
and not really jelling
with your roommate
and just feeling lonely
and then feeling guilty
that you feel lonely because
you're basically living
your dream at the same time.
- Yeah, and that
Olympians just don't,
we don't prepare for
the moment afterwards,
because if we did, we
probably wouldn't get there
in the first place and we
probably wouldn't do very well
if we were thinking
about anything but that.
- You can't plan beyond August.
- Yeah, you know that it's funny
because I've noticed that that
is true of other worlds too.
And I mentioned this,
but I met Jimmy Kimmel
on our press tour
for "Olympic Dreams"
when Nick was on his show.
And we talked about this,
like post Olympic depression,
like just the
subject of the movie.
And he was like, that's
exactly how I felt
after I hosted the "Oscars."
And I was like, oh, this
resonates with people
who have had singular goals.
And there's this dip
after where it's normal
but if you're not prepared for
it, which most of us aren't,
it's such a bizarre feeling.
- You see it with music,
I mean, you hear about
it with musicians,
they play a big show,
but then, they're on tour
and it's a different
city every night
and they're just alone in
their hotel room afterwards.
So the weird juxtaposition of
like this extreme experience
followed by this kind
of a weird liminal space
where you're just by yourself.
- Right, right.
I am sure there's
that in every world.
- Well, the only thing
though in the movie was,
I was like, where
are her teammates?
Like, she would be,
like, realistically,
she would have a team and
there would be a coach there
and there would be
people around for her.
So you created a more extreme
version of that experience.
- You know not
everybody has a coach.
Like there are country heads,
but most people can't
have their coach
in the village with them.
There are so few people-
- But there's a team,
like a team Olympic coach.
- There's a team Olympic coach.
So Penelope was supposed to
be from, like any country
that was sort of the IOCs hope,
and so she was not really
from a designated place.
And that was just
a universal athlete
is what they called her,
which I was down with.
But yeah, certainly, I mean,
but at the same time when
I think about my experience
in Rio, I was alone
most of the time.
Part of that was by choice.
- That makes me so sad.
- Why though?
Because I had so...
I was all eyeballs. I was
like taking it all in.
And I was sitting with
a different person
at the dining hall every night.
Like I remember one day I
sat and ate with this girl
and I did not know she was
'cause this was
before she competed,
but it was Katie
Ledecky, the swimmer,
and we had just like a
normal lunch together.
And it was just very
early in the games
and those opportunities
came about
because I chose to go to
the dining hall alone.
So I did that by choice
so that I could have a
different experience.
- Except when the dentist
asks you to hang out,
you said, no or
you didn't show up.
- I knew what happened at
the village pool, okay?
No savory things.
- All right, I hear you.
By the way, like give Gus
Kenworthy a movie immediately
like that guy's a movie star.
- Oh, he's amazing.
- He was so naturalistic
in his acting.
He crushed it.
- He acts.
He like me has these two,
he is multihyphenate
and multi-interested.
And that was cool
for me actually
because I hadn't met so many
people like me and I told him,
I was like, this is cool
to know that we both...
It helps me to
know that you exist
'cause it felt like I was
meeting somebody like-minded.
- Like, yeah, has he
done other movies?
- He was in "American
Horror Stories".
- [Host] Oh, he was?
Oh, I didn't know that.
- So I think he will
do more of that.
- That's cool. That's cool.
- Yeah, really cool.
- You talked about
this with Dave Chang
but I thought it was worth
spending a few moments on.
The moment where
after you've raced
and we don't really
know how you did,
we know that you're
not thrilled,
but there's a
creative choice to not
basically show the scoreboard
and what place you came
in or anything like that.
It's just a quiet
moment of reflection
where you're processing
what's going on.
And then you witness
a medal ceremony
and you see these women
getting their medals
and you're having an
emotional moment with that
as you're watching.
And then the aftermath
of that where the grips,
you know, the gaffers
or whoever come out
and remove the podium,
and you're like, oh yeah,
this is just a big show.
And it's like onto the next.
It's like the circus is in town
for a very brief moment of time,
and we're just
putting on a big show.
- I love that you
noticed that because,
and this is where I
think you and Jeremy
will get along very well,
because that was his,
that was his like
wholly Jeremy's vision.
And I think he likes seeing
like the mechanics of things
like that that we don't see,
like on NBC, you see
the medal ceremony,
you do not see it
being cleaned up.
And that was part of the
fun of "Olympic Dreams,"
was the showing that
the texture underneath
and like what happens
the moment after.
And I really love that
you pointed that out
because it's when you're
at these events in person,
as I'm sure anyone who is
involved in other like events,
there's so much more that goes
into it than just the event
in the medal ceremony.
- Right, it's like when you're
at Disneyland and
there's a whole like city
underneath your feet of people
that make that whole
place function.
- Yeah, it's so strange,
and it's not sad,
I think it's just
interesting, right?
- Well, I think it
gives you perspective,
like oh, I thought this
was like one thing,
but I realized like maybe
this isn't everything
I thought it was, you
could put a sad spin on it,
I don't think it's
necessarily sad,
but maybe I see it as
more transactional.
Like this is a
commercial enterprise.
- Interesting, yeah.
- Which maybe is cynical.
- Yeah, or maybe-
- Because I love
the "Olympic Dream."
I'm not casting
aspersions on that
but the production of
the Olympics is different
from the aspiration of
the "Olympic Dream."
- Yeah, but at the same
time, like when you think
about all the volunteers
and all the people
that make those moments happen,
it's also cool to think
about that it is so much more
than just the athletes
and the spectators.
Like there is this
whole, like, you know,
there are those people that
make it actually happen.
And we actually got to
interact with quite a few
of those people
because when we were,
when we shot in, for
example, the Olympic stadium
with the flame, with
nobody in there,
we had people helping us
like open those gates,
who knew we were
there to do the movie.
And just to know there
are all these people
who have been at so many
games, but on the other side,
they're the ones making it
happen, it's kind of cool.
Like, it's kind of
like when you think
about the chaperones
at the dance,
you're like, yeah,
we need those.
We need the people to help
make prom prom and it's cool.
- Will give some
attention to those people
in recounting your
own experience
just before
competing in the book
where you talk about like
the timing chip person
and they're the people that
are telling you go here,
and some people are very
detached from that role
and some people are
like very nurturing.
But just recognizing that there
are all these human beings
that are like the
grease to the engine.
- And they are not your parents
and they're not
your coach, right?
And that's where you're like,
why aren't the coaches there?
It's like, actually quite a
bit of the Olympic experiences
is you taking it in-
- Away from that.
- Yeah, you're away from that.
And that can really scare people
because so I think that
where people go wrong with...
I think the right
approach to the Olympics
is to not see it
like any other event,
to see it as something
exceptional and different.
When we try to sterilize
it and create it to be
just like every other race
or every other experience,
it will never be that
and it is so different.
And the people that I
knew who tried to recreate
their comfort zone
didn't do as well
because it's not your
comfort zone, it's different.
And maybe that's like a lesson
for anything we've
never done before.
Like it will be different and
control what you can, control,
but also embrace that
some of these things
are just gonna be different.
- Yeah, I mean, I
understand the impulse
to try to reduce it down to size
so that it becomes manageable
because when your whole life
is oriented around that moment,
it's very overwhelming, right?
So to say like I'm
just gonna make this
like every other race
but then you're less
resilient when you arrive.
And you're told to
do all these things
and you're kind of instructed
to go here and there,
and it's all very different,
that's gonna throw you
off and destabilize you
and perhaps undermine
the performance
that you're trying to
create for yourself.
- Yeah. Yeah.
If you could be in the
village, what was your,
where would you like to be
or what was like the most-
- Well, I mean, I'm
obsessed with the Olympics
but I've never
attended an Olympics.
So I don't know what that
experience would be like.
I have lots of friends
who've been Olympians
but it was cool in the movie,
I was like, oh, that's
what it looks like inside.
You know, it just
looked like really cold
and like a bunch of
tents, (laughs), you know,
it pulled the veneer off
like the glamour projection
that I had, I think.
You know, like there was
a bunch of young people-
- Yeah, bunch of kids
walking around.
- Hanging around.
And in the book, you describe
it as summer camp basically.
- Yeah, that's how it felt.
I mean, Rio was very romantic.
Rio was not cold. Rio
was very, very romantic.
I guess the winter
Olympics are romantic
in their own way though.
Everyone's huddled and just
need to keep each other warm.
- I know, I think I'd rather
be at the summer games.
But it did look like being
in the cafeteria was cool
'cause that's where you're
gonna have those collisions
with all those interesting
people and the people watching
and you recreate with Gus
something that you talked about
in the book, this idea
of like trying to imagine
what sport all of
these athletes play
and like what role they have,
and it's pretty cool.
- It was so fun.
The dining hall has the
best people watching.
It's just simply the best.
- It should be mentioned
that you can't just go
to the Olympics and
make a movie like you,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but you got the
support of the IOC
because they had
seen "Tracktown"
or whoever the
person in charge had
and granted you is
unprecedented access.
Like you basically could
go wherever you wanted.
- Yes, this was very rare.
The president of the
Olympics was really taken
by "Tracktown" which he
saw randomly on a flight,
which is the same,
that's the same with PTA, he
saw it randomly on the flight.
So thankful for those
airline distribution deals.
- Well, and also just
when you create something
and you put it out in the
world, you don't know,
you never know who it's
gonna connect with.
- Yeah, that's true.
I'm sure you feel that
way about this podcast
where anyone can find it.
- It is weird.
- Is it weird?
- Well, it's weird that
like your friend is a fan,
like that's an example
of that, right?
- Yes, that was like,
that put it in perspective
for me, where I was like,
wow, this really,
you know, these...
We make things and
we can't always know
or control where
they're going, but-
- You have the head of the
IOC and PTA and I have Amanda,
it's her name, Amanda, right?
- Uhuh! She's so...
- And I'll take
Amanda every time.
- You know what? That's
the right decision.
She's my best friend
since two years old.
And she appears to be the
only friend in my book,
I think two, I was
like, I realized.
'Cause sometimes, you
know, the characters,
it's important to
keep it relatively
simple but she's also-
- Well, you changed a few names.
- We did, yes.
So I'm sure you also
worked with a team
to know what was smart to
say and what not to say.
- I wish I could tell you
that I did, but I didn't.
- We had a lawyer.
- You had a team? Oh, wow.
- We had a lawyer
to make sure that-
- I didn't have any of that.
They were like, that looks good.
- Wow, we had a lawyer so that-
- I make up changes.
I got to rewrite it.
I did a new edition
of it and I went back
and changed a bunch
of that kind of stuff
'cause it was not, you know,
I wish I had had more
awareness around that.
- Yeah, I guess it's
just important that,
I mean, there were
certain people
like with Maya Rudolph's chapter
and with the chapter
where I mentioned
interactions with Bill Hader,
like I made sure to talk
to them and share
the chapter with them
and get their blessing because
I felt like those names,
I wanted to have them in there
'cause it was important
that it was them,
but it was also important to me
that they felt
comfortable with that.
It was more like the
virginity loss stories
and things like that where
it's like, these names will-
- Yeah, of course, so
you're telling some story
about something that
happened in high school
or somebody behaved badly,
there's no reason to use names.
- It's not useful.
I think like this, it's
just not useful, right?
So that's that.
- So, you have a TV show
that you guys are
working on now, right?
- Yes, so Jeremy and I...
The creative world is a
lot like playing tennis
where the ball will be in
your court for something
and then you hit it
out of your court,
I'm sure you can relate,
and you don't know when
you're gonna get it back
in certain scenarios and
that's why it's important
to have multiple
projects at once
because you don't want to just
be waiting there with idle,
like to have nothing
to do is your choice.
And so we always have multiple
creative projects going on.
And right now the
book is obviously
a big focus releasing it.
And then this TV show
opportunity came about
after the Rio Olympics.
And I can't say
so much about it,
other than that
it's very exciting
and set in the
Olympic village world
and it's going to be fabulous.
And it also feels like when
you shift from one event
to the another event in running,
where I've only
made feature films
and now we're learning
the television world,
and we're still
making feature films
and have those going on, but
I'm sure you can relate to,
I'm still playing the same sport
but it's a different event.
And there are things to learn
about television that are
different than feature.
- Yeah, 100%.
Meanwhile, you're going
from 10,000 meters
to the marathon, right?
- Exactly.
So I'm trying to switch events
and the marathon is still a
mystery to me, I'll be honest,
but I'm still
curious about it, so-
- When was that you
you've ran like a PR race
not that long ago?
I ran a nine-minute
PR this year,
but I know that
I have more in me
and that's because
it's a feeling
of where your mind and your
body are on the same page.
And I started to
get that in the 10K,
like I certainly felt it in Rio
and I haven't felt it
yet in the marathon.
And so I know that I
have potential still.
- How many marathons
have you run?
- Two.
- Right.
So how could you possibly
have it fully dialed.
- You couldn't I
suppose, or you could...
I only ran five 10Ks
in my life so far.
So it's like, it's not like-
(host laughing)
- Is that true? Wow!
- That's true.
I think Rio was my
fifth or something.
Rio might've even
been my fourth.
- That's crazy.
- I'm a late
bloomer in the sport
and I don't think it's how many
times you've run the event.
I think it's like,
I think...
You know, I don't think
it's just dependent on that,
but it does help, you
know, the experience helps.
What about you? I
mean, what did, what-
- Look at you trying
to turn the table?
- I'm always trying
to turn the table.
- I let you do it once or twice,
but we're done with that.
(Alexi laughing)
- So I still wanna
run another marathon.
I wanna break the Greek
record and whatnot.
- The Olympic
qualifying standard
got really rough this year.
- Oh my gosh, yeah.
- They dropped it
down significantly.
- By like 15 minutes.
- Yeah.
- I think that is going
to change the dynamic
at the Olympics where it'll
change it a bit, right?
Because if a standard
is more accessible,
it means that you're
definitely getting
the best in the world
not just the best,
or you're getting the best of
the world when it's accessible
and the faster and
faster the standard gets,
the more you're getting
the best in the world.
So, it's a shift I think.
- Right.
So you still would have to
drop a little bit of time
for you to make that standard
and compete for Greece, right?
- Yes.
- So how's it looking for Tokyo?
- Well, that time is
competitive, but doable.
That's how I feel about it.
And I think part of
it has been where
and when are the
racing opportunities,
and there've been a few,
but it's normally,
because of COVID,
it's normally not the
case that you're wondering
will I get a chance
to race safely?
It's normally like,
can I run this time?
And now there's both
of those factors.
And so most of COVID,
I've been focused...
Well, first of all, I was
supposed to run a race in March
and I ended up getting,
I went over to Greece-
- You got stuck.
- For five months.
Like I was supposed to be
there for like three weeks.
And so that was a really
life-changing experience.
And I shifted, you know, I
changed coaches out of necessity
'cause I was over there.
And I also shifted my focus
once the Olympics was pushed
to working on my weaknesses and
just trying to use this time
and it's still what I'm doing.
And so my goal is
to race in the like,
I think second half
of spring if things,
I'm hoping the world shifts,
but I'm also trying to respect
that there's a
pandemic going on.
- Yeah, yeah. So what
are those weaknesses?
- Yes, so I-
- I know you're working
with this like trainer guy
in Woodland Hills, right?
You were sharing about that,
so I was like, who is this?
I need to go see this guy.
- Oh, he's amazing.
- You gotta hook me out.
- Dag and Monica,
so I have my Greek coach
who worked a lot with me
on drills and agility.
And so like, I
really tapped back
into the more athletic
side of myself,
like the soccer instincts,
those are things that I feel
have worn off over time.
And so that's my coach
be honest in Greece.
And then with Dag and Monica,
I'm starting to access
and feel muscles
that I've never felt before,
and they're really, it's
posture related muscles,
but I can now flex like
the muscles around my spine
just like I might flex my bicep.
And I've never been
able to do that before.
Like just to flex, I'm
like doing it right now
and I've never felt that muscle.
And so what they've done,
and it's because we
have time to do this,
like we have time to start
a little bit back to basics
of like, can I hold myself in
a better position to sustain
what I believe and they
believe is a perfectly,
sustainable practice
of running for longer.
So they really have
helped me believe
that running is something
I'm meant to be doing
'cause I think sometimes runners
eventually in their career
are like, maybe I
can't do this anymore.
Maybe it's too hard or
your body's worn out.
I just wanna work on
supporting a movement
that humans are meant to do.
So it's been a lot
of mind shifting
to focusing on muscles
I never knew I had.
- That's fascinating. I need
to know more about this guy.
We'll talk more afterwards
'cause I need a little bit
more of that in my life.
And I think as
athletes, you wanna,
it's natural to kind of wanna
double down on your strengths
and everybody's so
concerned about making sure
that they're maximizing
their fitness
or getting their volume in
and their speed work
and all of that,
and especially as you age,
it's those pesky little things
that become much more important
and they're so annoying,
but if you do them and
they're pretty easy to do,
you become a much
more robust resilient
injury-proof athlete.
- Yes, and I've always
found that when you can
to be in person with
someone is a really big,
I mean, here we are talking
about this in this time,
but it's so with a coach
or with strength work,
like doing things remotely
is just there's something
about being impersonal
with someone.
I mean, I'm sure that's why
you're doing this right now
with me in person,
like it's different.
- Yeah, it is and it makes it
tricky and you have to be safe
and respect protocols
and things like that.
But there is a huge, sorry,
I didn't mean to step on your
words, but it is, you know,
the interpersonal
connection is so important.
- Yeah, yeah. I think so, too.
And it's, yeah...
Yeah, I'm excited to
talk to you more about it
'cause essentially it's
a little bit contrary.
Most people are like,
everybody's unique,
everyone needs different things
and this and that
and their philosophy.
Dag and Dr. Monica is more like,
actually we're a lot more
like cars than we think,
and we should be able
support this structure
and do this thing, and
there is a blueprint
and we can if we
strengthen certain muscles
that you didn't know you had.
You can support
this, speaking of,
you don't wanna be unique
when it comes to body
and injury things.
And I think that's what's
been so comforting,
is they're like, no
you're not unique.
- Well, we all have the
same bones and muscles,
we start there.
- Exactly. Exactly.
So it's been really helpful.
And I like working with people
who have a diverse perspective.
So like a lot of
the work they do
is with tennis players
and football players.
And I think I've worked with
a lot of running specialist
people and that's been helpful,
but sometimes it's refreshing
to step outside and just-
- Mix it up a little bit.
- Yeah.
And just look at the
body, not just...
- How much of the running is
on pavement versus trails?
- Oh, I love trails.
I mean, why did I
move to the Valley?
Because I wanted to
soak up all the trails.
- 818 baby.
- I love it.
So I try to run soft
for all easy runs.
I end up needing to go
on a track or on roads
for some of these workouts
because I have to train my body
to handle certain services,
but I'm on soft and on
trails as much as I can.
And I love it.
I love how undiscovered the
trails of LA seemed to be.
I know that there are
people running here
but it's not something that
people talk about in the world.
- It's crazy to me
because the trail system,
the amount of like untouched
land in Los Angeles
is pretty extraordinary,
but it's kind of blind
to the casual observer
who's just driving
on the freeway.
Like you see the
hills over there,
but then when you're
actually up there,
yeah, there's a few runners
and now with gravel bikes,
there's more people on bikes,
but overall, there's
barely anybody up there
and you could be up
in Topanga State Park
and it's like natural land
for as far as you can see
and you're right in the
middle of Los Angeles.
It makes Central Park
look like a speck
compared to what's
available here.
And when you're up there-
- Quote him, okay.
I said quote him.
(both laughing)
- I mean, when you're
up there you're like,
why isn't everybody up here?
Like, there's no...
For such a densely
populated urban metropolis,
I'll see like three
people, you know,
in like over a course
of multiple hours.
- Yeah, and I feel
that the greatest gift
that people have given me here
and that you could give
someone if you're interested
in running in trails or walking
is to show them a trail.
Because you don't know
that they're there, right?
- And you know, I'll
call myself out on that.
Like I lived here for years
before I ever went and
explored any of it.
And then when I did, I was
like, oh my God, I had no idea.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, I'm loving it.
I feel it's a
forever place for me.
And I've met friends
through the trail system
like while on the
trail I've met friends,
and it's just like
a treasure trove.
I love the early mornings and
in the sunsets are the best
and it is a good
way to get to know
a city is on the trails I think.
- Well, we got to end
this shortly here.
I don't wanna be too
indulgent with your time,
but before I let you go,
I think a good way to
end it is with just a few
sort of bravey thoughts for
the person who's listening,
who's maybe feeling
stuck or struggling
or feels like they're not
entitled to have a dream
or that aspirational life
that they seek, you know,
just feels too inaccessible.
- Well, to you
bravey listening in,
I take your dream seriously,
even if you do not.
So you're allowed to take
it seriously as well.
I think also bravey,
the way that you feel right now
will probably not be
how you feel forever
even if it seems like you will.
I think that would
have been a nice thing
for someone to tell me,
oh, I think my dad
sort of did tell me
when I was feeling really
down, but I didn't believe him.
So I hope that helps and,
just know that we're
satellite teammates.
- I love it.
- Sometimes people
become teammate.
- I don't know what to say.
(both laughing)
- I'm so exited
that you live here.
- No, listen-
- I only have one friend, okay?
- I am in love with
everything that you are about,
you just delight me.
And I'm so pleased
that you took the time
to come here and share today.
- Thank you for having me.
- I love-
- I wanna tell you more
about our film projects too.
- Please, you're gonna
come over for dinner
and I'm gonna subject you
to a lot of vegan food
whether you like it or not.
- One of my training
partners is vegan
and I lived with her
in Mammoth for a month,
and I learned so much.
And Jeremy has not to like,
but Jeremy is technically
not supposed to eat
like dairy for example,
- Right.
- But we didn't understand
how simple that shift would be
until I lived with her and I
just saw what she was eating
and just ate with her,
and that was really helpful.
So we're more vegan
than we used to be.
- To be continued.
- Perfect.
- And I can't wait for your
book to be out in the world
and for everybody to enjoy
what I'm enjoying right now.
So nothing but mad
love and respect
for everything that you
and Jeremy are about.
And I can't wait to
see what you do next.
- We're gonna plant some seeds
and those flowers are
gonna sprout next year.
- Cool, in the meantime,
pick up "Bravey"
at your fine
independent bookstore
or on Amazon 'cause
we're in a pandemic.
- I didn't realize this
is still being recorded.
Poor Jeremy, I'm like,
Jeremy has a dairy allergy.
- No, it's fun.
And if you want to
learn more about Alexi,
well, go to your website,
you're easy to find
on the internet.
- Yep, I think-
- Alexipappas.com,
@Alexipappas, anything else
you wanna alert people to?
- Just get that "Bravery" book.
(host laughing)
- All right, come back
and talk to me again.
- I will thank you for
having me and thank you
for your belief in me.
- You're very welcome.
Thank you for coming.
- It's huge.
- It's cool.
Peace, plants.
- Peace, plants.
(host laughing)
(upbeat music)